et bienvenue pour ce nouveau tournoi ça
lui Fab salut que salut à tous donc Fab
on est parti pour suivre cet
extraordinaire tournoi donc la finale du
chest.com Global Championship 2022 avec
énormément d'argent dans jeu pour un
pour un tournoi internet puisque dans
celui-ci il y a un million de dollars de
prix donc c'est assez exceptionnel et on
a on a tous les tous les gros joueurs
internet là qui se sont qui se sont
qualifiés pour pour ce tournoi Fab le
gratin est là on a
Nakamura évidemment qui qui gagne qui
gagne tous les tous les tous les titles
qui est toujours là bien placé André Kin
aussi très gros joueur internet rajabov
voilà
qui est un habitué des des joutes
internet Niall Sarine aussi un des tous
meilleurs joueurs sur sur chiasse.com
et quelques invités surprises j'ai envie
de dire deux Douda et
qui eux sont moins habitués à assez
juste là et aussi ça me sévit en lui
aussi habitué mais qui s'était fait
éliminé par par les bonnes
mais qui voilà les bonnes qui a pas pu
venir finalement et donc qui reprend
quelques sortes sa place mais voilà une
des spécialistes Fabien dans dans ce
dans ce tournoi et de deux petites
surprises et je te propose qu'on suive
pour le premier match du DA contre
camion ouais bah une grosse affiche non
grosse affiche effectivement gros sa
fille grosse affiche
je crois que c'est ce qu'il y a à dire
Fabien là dessus c'est une grosse
affiche
joueur du tournoi qui se rencontrent au
premier tour en fait enfin en fin pas au
premier tour mais au premier tour en
réel et du coup le perdant est éliminé
quoi parce que voilà c'est ouais bon
terminé
est-ce que tu te poses des est-ce que tu
es tu te poses
[Musique]
sur deux jours trois jours semaine on ne
sait plus alors non c'est sur deux jours
donc c'est en 15 + 2 donc la Ham 15
minutes tu joues ta partie hop tu as les
petites 2 secondes qui viennent de les
petites bouffées d'air pour souffler
quatre parties tous les jours donc
quatre parties aujourd'hui quatre
parties de 20 tac tac et il se passe
quoi si il y a 4 4 Armageddon enfin j'ai
deux questions d'ailleurs est-ce que
c'est deux matchs différents c'est la
suite
genre tu gagnes le premier match 4-0 tu
perds le 2e 2 et demi oh là là c'est une
bonne question mais de ce que j'ai lu
c'est le même match attention ok
d'accord ce que j'ai eu c'est le même
match et c'est vrai que c'est c'est vrai
que c'est une bonne question c'est vrai
que il y a des questions Fab auquel j'ai
pas non mais moi j'ai lu que c'était 8
matchs mais je me suis pas posé la
question en fait j'ai lu huit parties 15
+ 2 les parties débutent toutes les
heures et en cas de match nul on verra
on verra l'Armageddon
mais ce que ça répond un peu à ta
question quand même
est-ce que ça te rend heureux
relativement enfin je veux dire on va
voir un peu le contenu etc vu de loin tu
te dis bon le format est pas ouf
malheureusement mais peut-être peut-être
que le contenu
émerveiller et qu'on va déborder
l'enthousiasme on va voir ah ouais moi
je suis très très chaud je suis très
très chaud surtout pour pour ce premier
match Fab qui va être extraordinaire
est-ce que je l'ai joué non non je
connais personne qui l'a joué sauf alors
il y a Maxime mais il était qualifié
d'office mais il a joué on va dire
complètement à l'arrache il y a Jules
qui a tenté de se qualifier il a pas
réussi c'est les deux seuls
joueurs que je connais qui ont qui ont
essayé de de se qualifier alors attends
faut que je mette moi du bon côté parce
que c'est Naka qui a les blancs faut que
je remette bien les caméras mais non non
je connais personne qui
[Musique]
pas du tout
ils n'ont pas essayé pas intéressé pour
parler un million de dollars Fabien
pourtant tu vois million de dollars mais
ils ont dû se dire qu'ils étaient
difficiles à aller chercher
peut-être de leur temps et donc ils ont
décidé de de ne pas jouer le tournoi
donc tournoi qui a pas
d'y aller foule en fait
non mais c'est un peu dommage c'est vrai
puisque vu les prix et tout ça on aurait
pu s'attendre un truc extraordinaire et
bon vu comme ça on va dire ça
plus
ça a plus attiré les les spécialistes de
ces jeux là
donc les spécialistes des formats
Internet et les joueurs qui sont plus
habitués à
jouer en réel ont moins ont moins moins
participé tu vois bah qui s'est dit bon
je vous détaille toutes les semaines je
fais jamais de prix c'est bon je vais
pas y jouer il y a des joueurs après
moins habitués qui ont tenté quand même
leur chance je pense à greachuk je
pensais qu'ils vont habitué mais ils ont
pas réussi à lutter
Fabien parce qu'il y a quand même des
sacrés sommes à aller prendre et qui est
le favori alors je pense que ce son d'un
camera et Douda qui se rencontrent au
premier tour pour moi les deux favoris
après avoir
avoir ce qu'il en est
avoir ce qu'il en est donc là on a dans
cette ouverture une pétrole et qui a été
joué un petit peu dans le style d'un
Gambie moi d'une Française d'échange
genre pas tout à fait ils ont pas fait
la transposition mais ça peut un petit
peu ressembler ou à une berlinoise
Fabien et on voit les blancs quand même
nettement mieux ici enfin nettement
mieux un petit peu mieux qui ont ce cet
avantage à long terme ouais bon alors
c'est une structure effectivement
symétrique et donc quand c'est une
structure symétrique ce qui peut donner
l'avantage ou pas ça peut être le
placement des pièces
et on voit donc les blancs sont un peu
plus actifs avec le contrôle de la
colonne a déjà avec la tour dessus la
seule colonne ouverte et ils ont envoyé
un cahier 5 qui pousse un pion h là pour
aller un peu ils ont provoqué le coup
j'hésiste évidemment pour éviter mat
donc peut-être voilà une petite
initiative pour les blancs après reste à
voir si ça peut être matérialisé on sait
que Douda est quand même un expert dans
ces pétrole c'est un moment qu'il les
joue et il connaît bien après moi tu me
montres la position comme ça je me dis
bah c'est une réussite pour les blancs
c'est ouverture mais tu vois il a pas
l'air trop sourciller
il a pris qu'une minute 30 pour jouer le
début bon après oui la case de 5 elle
donne envie
tu dis qu'il y a un peu des faiblesses à
droite à gauche que toi tu peux venir au
5 E4 les Noirs n'auront pas parce qu'on
aura F3
donc ouais je préfère les blancs mais
avoir un peu ça peut se matérialiser
et par contre tu as un mauvais fou
ouais alors pareil relatif si je plante
en E5 il sera quand même pas mal
il sera quand même pas mal tu vois tu es
fou ou 5 derrière bon mais tu pars à 4
mais je veux dire tu peux le mettre il
sera il sera beau quoi et le roi un peu
faible peut-être non tous ces Punto qui
ont avancé là un peu devant ou pas du
vent je sais pas trop
elle être après bah en gros dudat il te
dit bah j'ai donné mon coup de caisse
blanche du coup je mets les pions sur
caisse blanche pour pour compenser
avoir bon j'ai l'impression de préférer
les blancs mais si ça se trouve c'est
plus visuel qu'autre chose je connais
pas assez bien peut-être les détails en
profondeur de la position
même au classement en partie longue à la
suite des candidats un petit peu de
lassitude chez le joueur polonais
qui en a peut-être mieux un peu marre
des échecs pour pour dire les choses
de manière un peu simple et directe
je sais pas en fait
en tout cas il a baissé
alors qu'on attendait
je pense que c'est un joueur de coup
comme il a fait la Coupe du Monde ou
quoi mais pas sûr qu'il aura la
régularité tout le temps il nous fait ça
ça fait déjà un petit moment au début on
se dit ouais il est jeune ou quoi mais
je crois que c'est juste un peu comme
comme ça quoi avec lui c'est un joueur
un joueur d'un tournoi quoi jouer en
tournoi un moment donné il le coche il
le joue
ouais ou alors peut-être qu'il est que
je tousse que quand il est pas en forme
il arrive juste pas après j'en sais rien
tu vois je n'ai pas demandé exactement
mais je sais qu'il a déjà bien planifié
ces tournois pour l'an prochain etc
enfin il est pas là ce que j'arrête ou
je continue quoi mais ouais peut-être
souffler après les candidats ça fait pas
de mal c'était une grosse période de
prépa quand même c'est un gros truc et
puis peut-être qu'il était déçu qu'il
espérait mieux et qu'il faut le temps de
se de se remettre d'une déception
pour se remettre il rejoue tempo en
disant tiens ça me fait penser à autre
chose ou enfin je rejoue et je me remets
d'autres ont besoin de souffler enfin
bref je sais pas ça dépend
bon ben là maintenant je souffle tout le
temps mais de base de base je pense
c'est pas si con de rejouer sauf si tu
es en peu vraiment plus que tu joues
trop mal si tu joues trop mal c'est rien
de t'enfoncer comme un con mais sinon ne
pas jouer parfaitement ça arrive quand
même assez souvent donc c'est pas si
grave
je suis d'accord avec toi
on va voir on va laisser la partie se
développer pour vraiment le roi est un
peu faible et Douda qui réfléchit n'a
qu'à qui danse
ça pourrait être un match très directeur
nous on va suivre ce match là c'est la
plus belle affiche donc on va faire
comme on fait d'habitude on a choisi ce
match en grand format puis on suivra
l'évolution du score dans les autres
matchs
et puis on décidera après si ce match là
n'est vraiment pas serré de de choisir
celui qui semble le plus intéressant à
savoir aussi petite règle intéressante
c'est que les horaires sont assez
faciles à suivre puisque ça joue une
partie au début de chaque heure Fab donc
une partie aujourd'hui à 17h une à 18h
une à 19h une à 20h donc c'est ça c'est
aussi assez intéressant finalement cette
cette innovation d'avoir un
un calendrier des heures un agenda
vraiment très très compréhensible ouais
non ça c'est bien
pour le coup c'est bien souvent
réclamait que bon on est plus de clarté
au moins au moins ça va au moins on sait
quand les parties commencent et quand
elles s'arrête donc on aura à peu près 4
heures de jeu tous les jours voilà
peut-être un peu moins même peut-être un
peu moins même et donc les matchs durant
du roi à peu près on va dire 7h30 de
duel sur sur huit parties si évidemment
le match n'est pas gagné avant donc il a
mis les cavaliers aussi suivi en taper
en F4 en D4 écoute il fait un peu sa vie
de cavalier ce que tu penses qu'on
pourrait être bien sûr ou
se passe en fait
huit parties alors après j'ai pas réussi
ouais la finale sera aussi envie de
partir c'était c'est dommage peut-être
qu'il y ait pas quelques parties en plus
pour pour la finale et qu'elle garde le
même format tu sais un petit peu comme
au tennis dans une époque dans les
masters ou les ou les ou les finales
étaient en 5 7
un autre format aurait pu imaginer
on aurait pu imaginer une finale en 12
voire 16 voire même 24 parties pourquoi
pas avec peut-être différents formats du
960 au milieu du Blitz du Bullet ça
aurait pu
ça aurait pu
donc cavalier aussi ça coûte ça quand
même pas l'air terrible pour les Noirs
non
on va voir c'est un peu moche en fait il
y a trop de trous dans la position les
pions trop avancé donc il prend une fois
j'adore le coup de leur dire là le coup
même cavalier G4 tellement jolie
trouvable très trouvable en fait
faut y penser mais c'est trouvable
tu veux juste venir en E5 et si il prend
tu prends G6 cavalier G7 et ça a l'air
bien c'est trouvable c'est pas facile
c'est pas un coussin on va pas se mentir
c'est pas un coup facile cavalier G4
mais en 15 + 2 quand tu as l'aisance
tactique d'un nikaru c'est un coup qui
est trouvable
c'est peut-être plus trouvable même si
c'était le seul bon coup bah il le fait
cavalier G4 mais ouais ça sentait que
c'était trouvable ouais bien sûr c'est
complètement dans ses cordes
on a envie de mettre un cabanon
et il l'a bien vu donc ouais ben ça va
taper un peu G6 et en plus la troisième
rangée dispo maintenant pour que la dame
coulisse éventuellement slash la tour
donc
je me posais des questions parce que des
fois tu as des positions qui ont l'air
dégueulasse mais le mecs connaissent
tout par cœur ils ont fait de l'ordi et
en fait ça va bon là ça juste l'air
d'être vraiment pourri ouais c'était
c'est l'ouverture a complètement été
ratée et il se met tout de suite en
grand danger hein Douda parce que déjà
kikaru semble être quand même le favori
sur le papier ou une défaite là alors
lors de cette première partie lui
mettrait vraiment un gros coup de bambou
derrière la tête et même peut-être
devant la tête d'ailleurs pourquoi le
coup de bambou devrait être que derrière
Fab ah bah dans toute la tête
BIM le coup de bambou qui tombe et ouais
bon là j'ai envie de dire c'est match
déjà quasiment terminé non quand même
pas mais
ouais enfin je pense que c'est à deux
points d'écart pour tourne ce soir à 3
il peut il peut ne pas revenir demain
qui sera là cliqué mais bon après non
compris car oui il faut pas le laisser
prendre le large comme ça et dès la
première partie rater son ouverture de
telle manière c'est quand même dommage
oui surtout que la pétrole il connaît
enfin je suis pas sûr qu'il y a aussi
une grosse nouveauté tu vois je sais pas
je pourrais regarder un peu mais c'était
quoi vas-y je vais cliquer les coups
voir où est-ce que ça divergé pardon ce
qui est normal E4 5 F3 qui est 6 il a
bouffé d'ici il est parti qui est tac
tac c'était quoi fou des trois fois
donc ça c'est du classique enfin c'est
une des nouvelles ventes à la mode il a
quand on dit si c'est ça
et là quoi qu'elle est fin ou attends
plus je sais tout les trois mais peu
importe il faut F4 vous prend des trois
dans trois cavaliers à 6 ok mais je
crois qu'on a déjà joué comme ça au
public ça me dit quelque chose c'est sûr
H4
c'est pas la partie contre jade
d'ailleurs
mais genre avant H4 qui est set qui est
G5 et là il a fait G6 ok c'était pas
tout à fait la même position mais ok
c'est H4 qui est C7 il y a 12 parties
que j'ai 5 G6 ça existe toujours genre
il y a kerwana Mehdi Rohff 3 déjà donc
tout a déjà eu exactement ça Clio III
ouais il est jeune dame des 7 mari il a
fait refait Dame des 7 h 5 h 5 euh H5
c'est le coup de saut elles ont déjà
joué ça un truc de Magnus là l'opéra
machin il est effectué C8 là il a changé
il a fait F5 ouais mais F5 ça avait
l'air vraiment pourri cavalier H3
là le petit ordi dit que c'était
cavalier aussi la faute qu'il fallait
faire fouf si attention non mais bon ce
qu'il y a de bizarre enfin je veux mon
ordi bon il est pas puissance de ouf
mais il est à pied 24 là pour commencer
il est déjà plus 0,30 pour les blancs
quoi le ce qui dit c'est de confirmer un
peu
ouais bizarre cette ligne après ça si ça
a été joué par autant de joueurs de haut
niveau c'est peut-être le F5 qui qui
n'allait pas tout simplement ouais où il
l'a confondu enfin
bref ok donc pour en venir là bah ouais
après que j'ai 4 il est en souffrance en
plus la pendule bah il y a déjà 6
minutes de retard ça commence à peser
ah ouais ça vaut son petit pesant de
cacahuètes Fab le temps et
bon il a pas l'air bien non
alors il joue d'où il est en Serbie dans
le Canada il est parti
alors lui je crois ou d'ailleurs en fait
alors je crois que ça c'est assez simple
je crois qu'il y en a trois qui sont
Serbie c'est André quian
et tous les autres au Canada
si j'ai pas fait de d'erreur c'est bien
ça Fabien
partie intéressante Hikaru qui va qui
met à mal son adversaire
[Musique]
bon cela dit de la Coupe qu'à moitié
enfin sûrement que il va quand même
mettre le cavalier en E5 et sur quel
écran mettre le fou quoi
les gens veulent la barre des Vals comme
c'est fait pour écouter on va la mettre
une petite barre des Vals alors je sais
pas pourquoi ça a tourné l'échiquier
et ben voilà la barre des vagues qui est
belle c'est magnifique Fabien
[Musique]
du blanc
c'est bien blanc
c'est bien blanc voilà bar des vannes
magnifique
cette barre des Vals
elle va presque dans le 5 quand même
c'est pas rien
qui va dur 5 cavalier prend fou prends
ça va échanger dame j'ai trois cavalier
4 tours de Tours j'ai l'impression que
ça se joue tout seul en plus comme
position
ça c'est simple il y a pas besoin de
chercher des coups de ouf c'est que des
coups naturels
ok oui
ce qu'on arrive à jouer sans barre
là on comprend on comprend nettement
mieux la position voilà après le design
il est fait pour avoir la barre d'eval
normalement de chaise comme ils veulent
la mettre donc écoute on va la mettre
Fab on leur fait plaisir voilà on leur
fait plaisir tout le monde est content
c'est leur budget
il y a beaucoup de budget sur cette
barre Fab mettons de la barre à fond
ça va être marrant de
on sait pas ce qu'il joue
un million de dollars Théodore
mais je sais pas ce que j'ai vu un
million 200000 un million j'ai vu les
deux chiffres alors après Euro Dollar on
ne sait pas mais je crois que là c'est
200000 au premier enfin c'est magnifique
en fait c'est beau extraordinaire
c'est vrai que tu as des joueurs qui se
sont vraiment spécialisés sur sur
internet je pense je pense notamment à
Raja BOV qui qui joue vraiment très très
bien sur Internet et c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'au final quand tu
cumules les prix des tournois de chatcom
et des tournois Magnus tu vas tu as plus
de prix que sur les tournants réels sur
une saison et voilà c'est vrai que c'est
bien tranquille chez toi c'est vrai
pourquoi se fatiguer à voyager quoi en
fait ouais ouais mais c'est André Kid
aussi les deux qui se sont vraiment
spécialisés sur ces tournants là au
final c'est pas idiot un Fab de de
vraiment faire quasiment que de
l'Internet il y a plus d'argent
et et c'est vrai que c'est c'est une
manière de voir les choses et c'est et
c'est loin d'être bête
bah c'est pragmatique c'est très
pragmatique ouais
c'est très pragmatique et c'est bien
joué de leur part
et c'est très bien pensé de leur part là
il Caro qui réfléchit qui lui aussi un
spa lui on va dire icaru il est
spécialiste de tout en fait mais quand
même aussi assez spécialisé depuis
longtemps
bien joué mais logique bien
on voit que la barre ne bouge pas donc
c'est si on est beaucoup de temps c'est
un petit peu monter ouais mais bon après
le truc c'est que
c'est pas trop Fab mais le problème
après de ces ordi c'est que la
profondeur est tellement basse qu'on
peut pas trop lui faire confiance mais
bon ça fait plaisir de l'avoir quand
même on se demande est-ce qu'il fallait
vraiment faire [ __ ] peut-être mais
c'est beau parce qu'en jouant les deux
coups qu'elle proposait elle a un peu
baissé quoi non finalement je change la
vie je t'emmerde je voulais pas faire ça
est-ce que tu penses qu'elle redescend
un peu ou qu'elle remonte là au prochain
coup
bah ça va dépendre du coup de Douda quoi
vas-y écoute on va regarder cette barre
pour est-ce que tu penses qu'elle
dépasse le 5 complètement ou pas au
prochain coup genre je parle pas de la
cage je parle du chiffre là le 5 après
coup noir puis couvre après connard et
tu penses qu'elle devait pas
non elle peut être à hauteur du 5 mais
je pense pas que ce sera tout en haut du
5 attends attends
elle a un peu embêté c'est marrant parce
que c'était son premier coup un tour à 8
mais quand elle était il était content
il était content alors dit que ce soit
joué
on va dire on va voir on va voir si ça
monte si ça descend au prochain coup
fabika roux qui hésitent en tout cas eux
ils la voient pas à la barre
malheureusement ce serait beau de voir
la barre en fait
bon
il pourrait avoir appel à la barre quoi
appelle un ami ils sont là ce serait une
idée ça aux échecs avec la barre d'avoir
le droit à la barre d'évaluation
normalement c'est censé être plutôt une
bonne aide parce que oui
tu sais s'il y a un truc à trouver ou
pas en tout cas si tu as la barre tu
sais ouais donc c'est intéressant ouais
ça peut être intéressant d'avoir cette
barre
d'après d'indications ouais mais bon ça
mais peut-être aussi plus les gens sur
un pied d'égalité de tout savoir là-bas
ça peut être une idée allez tour 2
e ouverte
et la barre qui reste à peu près mais
moi je pense que tout d'un coup elle va
s'envoler cette barre
moi j'avoue son volet Fab non peut-être
pas au coup prochain mais tout d'un coup
ça va il y aura une connerie
cette barre qui est magnifique Fab
on va voir comment comment Douda
continuer ce qui va trouver le coup qui
permet de maintenir cette barre on va
dire dans la case du 5
maintenant à peu près la normalité de
là-bas pas qu'elle s'envole jusqu'au
ciel si tu montes dans le 6 déjà tu es
dans le dur faut vraiment rester dans le
5 déjà dans le 5 tu es pas super mais
ouais ça va encore quoi tu as qu'une
case de manger par là-bas
te prends trop d'espace après c'est
exponentiel elle monte de plus en plus
quoi
ok admettons en tout cas pour le moment
il réussit à réussir à se maintenir
il réussit à se maintenir dans la zone
du 5 c'est bien joué hein ok j'ai 5 bons
responsables évidemment parce que bon
parle-moi de barre
la barre confirme
tu prends la case F4 voilà est-ce que tu
penses est-ce que si tu pousses F4 tu
penses que la barre s'envole ou pas
Adam G6 ouais c'est la problématique
quand même on essaye vas-y genre si tu
joues ça
va complètement ouais il faut pas le
faire alors Fab non non
tout petit peu peut-être j'ai quatre qui
appartient pour justement enlever ce
Pione qui part
ouais
il en profite pas
ah il doit penser pareil que nous il
doit dire il va faire une erreur à un
moment donné elle va s'envoler toute
seule j'aurais besoin de faire
j'attendais conneries toi
mais sur G4 on sait pas mais ça peut pas
être un coup gagnant physique c'est ça
qui est cool c'est comment là on le sait
grâce à cette application
tant qu'elle s'envole pas on est
tranquille on sait qu'il y a rien à
trouver on est un peu en chaussons du
coup
peut-être ramener le cavalier en F2
comme ça quoi pour faire peut-être G4 et
rebondir
après G4 le coup d'avance j'aimais bien
mais bon voilà après ce qui veut ouvrir
un nouveau front faire un B3 C4 on va
voir quoi
ça lui décidait
c'est lui qui joue au final Fab
cavalier
il se fait grignoter il se fait
grignoter le genre américain
voilà mais bon après il peut faire une
guerre d'usure à se dire de toute façon
on t'a pendule elle restera elle restera
comme elle est quoi la part monter si
vite
en tout cas ça défend ça défend pour le
moment qu'on était côté il y a une crise
mais là il doit peut-être pas loin de la
tenir quand même maintenant il a les la
dernière série de 10 15 quoi plutôt été
à en sa faveur à Douda ouais bon disons
il a pas mis le coup derrière la tête
mais ça reste pas bête pour les lampes
en fait il a envie de mettre le
calendrier des trois c'est pour ça que
la dame et que le cavalier vienne se
diriger soit en C5 soit à la place du
Fou éventuellement la Dame des donne un
peu chiante elle t'évite de doubler les
tours tu aurais bien aimé faire
peut-être te recettes mais bon bah tu
couvre ton fou donc j'ai 5 sera en
prises et donc il te cumule des petits
trucs chiants alors que ok l'ordi ça
part de l'impressionner bon il va te
défendre mais humainement ça renforce en
fait il a doublé le tour sur la colonne
ouverte il ramène son cavalier qui était
à l'aise il va le mettre en D3 donc en
fait en soi c'est pas c'est pas mal hein
tu vois j'imagine qu'il y ait des trois
maintenant
sur la position
là c'est dur
que tu vas faire la moindre précision ça
va être balayé quoi
donc
ouais donc difficile terrible
c'est terrible pour pour Jean-Christophe
qui suit
mais voilà ça y est ça rentre dans le 6
Fab ouais c'est pas mon signe ça c'était
sûr en fait ça peut pas du tout marcher
ce qui fait
les carreau qui va encore marcher sur le
tournoi ouais je pense qu'il va le
gagner très facilement ce tournoi
personnellement
je sais pas trop qui pour aller
l'embêter
maintenant
Sarine c'est sûr que non
je sais pas s'il est très sérieux bien
préparé que tu prends pas trop la
montage c'est pas une séance trop rapide
en 15 minutes tu peux peut-être un peu
mais bon il est moins fort en 15 unités
peut-être sur un petit peu match
sinon ça les autres ça me paraît
vraiment impossible
ça me paraît trop en dessous
ouais là la position elle est en train
de s'effriter côté noir comme tu l'as
expliqué il y a maintenant une vingtaine
de minutes c'est un petit peu le la
résultante de ce que tu disais bah ouais
bon on laisse jamais huit déjà il y a
une pièce et ben on a complètement le
contrôle de la colonne c'est 5 très
pénible attaque B7 il est défendu mais
tu vois ça fait juste une faiblesse en
plus
tu as le droit à gérer tu as la huitième
range à gérer ta B7 à gérer parce qu'on
sert beaucoup de choses en vérité là
vous avez la jugeant à gauche mais à ce
moment ça m'étonnerait pas déjà dans le
7 voire même dans le 8 ça c'est trop là
et là ce qui a trouvé c'est qu'elle
prend B7 mais c'est assez facile
ouais dame prend de Me huit trois G7
fois
le matériel mais on va quand même
bouffer pas mal de pions ils vont être
FM et on va bouffer un minimum encore
ces 6 dessins ouais tu vas avoir fou
cavalier tour contre dame et tu auras
toutes tes pièces désorganisé et le roi
faible donc ça gagne très facilement ça
va être trouvé Paris carreau
donc là c'est en fait c'est ça la force
d'avoir la barre d'évaluation c'est que
si tu l'as tu as pas besoin le coup tu
le trouves en fait c'est ça tu sais que
tu as un truc à trouver et qui est
professeur
a priori il y a rien d'autre de
t'entendre tu peux y aller même sans
rien voir c'est ça mais basiquement en
fait la barre c'est comme quand vous
exercices vous savez qu'il y a un truc à
trouver alors quand vous partez vous en
savez rien
ok oui mais donc là c'est extrêmement
c'est extrêmement simple et là ça va
être qui est prend B7
qui va être joué
on attend le coup et ça va faire un zéro
instantanément je crois pas que les
autres parties soient terminés parce
qu'on a un petit un petit design score
en dessous de nos têtes et donc
normalement si un but est marqué on le
voit on a le droit
écoute ça à faire des gens zéro un
pourri carreau match qui commence sur
des chapeaux de roue
un peu trop facile
ouais après
on s'attendait pas forcément à autre
chose non plus on va voir si avec les
Blancs d'ouda réussit à mettre un peu de
pression ou si sombre rapidement
faudrait qu'ils puissent réagir
parce que bon déjà les embarquer mais
alors évidemment si il se prend deux
buts sur coup
ça rappellera un match de synthé super
la deuxième fable
dans les autres parties est-ce que on
peut
jeter un coup un coup d’œil rapide alors
ça c'est
bon
en même temps en fait
il y a souvent
[Musique]
spécialiste aussi internet ça m'étonne
pas un qui souffre il a beaucoup de mal
en ce moment Wesley et
qui est d'autre
[Musique]
il s'accroche avec les Blancs il fait ce
qu'il peut c'est un peu dur
[Musique]
et là le truc c'est qu'il va commencer à
gober tous les pions quoi donc il en a
déjà trois mais en plus assister 6 on
pas de simples à défendre j'ai envie de
dire surtout C6 surtout assise pardon
et du coup
il y a déjà trois pions c'est des pions
qui peuvent avancer
attention après le seul truc enfin qui
peut arriver si tu fais genre kg 6
cavalier F4 tu as tout qui se défend
ouais t'attaque un peu G2
on sait jamais aussi mais bon
normalement ça va jamais trop passer
tout ça ah ouais ça c'est terrible hier
je l'ai rencontré sur chesska mais il
m'a il m'a apporté la partie mais bon
sûrement échaudé par par sa défaite il y
a deux trois semaines
attention menace oh là là si tu fais
dames c'est huit la barre s'envole non
ah non
et là si tu fais genre dame C1
j'ai trois la barre s'envole ou pas on
essaye
d'ailleurs il peut attendre avant de le
faire le il a fait mais c'est pas sûr
qu'il gagne en fait
elle m'a pas l'air d'être si simple
celle-là alors
ici à faire cavalier H7 F6 au 4
alors peut-être
mais tu dois pas y arriver par contre
ouais quatre secondes c'est trop peu
arrivé de cacher le roi vers les pions
[Musique]
et essayer de faire face de l'autre côté
mais bon ça va pas être facile
de plus elle serait peut-être nul oui
mais même là elle est pas enfin je suis
pas sûr que fondamentalement elle soit
gagnante
non mais bon entre le temps et tout ça
il y a trop de problèmes mais
mais si tu as beaucoup de temps ou que
tu es un ordinateur je pense que tu as
des chances de la défendre ça là
un ordi oui il va il va pas
alors dit contre ordi tu peux peut-être
la défendre
le truc c'est qu'en fait il faut qu'il
faudrait qu'il réussisse à laisser les
pions avancer en F5 et G4 mettre le fou
sur sa diagonale et faire le blocus
allez il faut cliquer
le cheval non
ah il veut cliquer comme ça
je pense qu'il veut clic clic clic
jusqu'en E4 donc il veut pas re bouger
son cheval mais là il menace pas
cavalier cette malheureusement pas
encore
ça va ça y est il joue beaucoup mieux
depuis qu'il clique ah bah oui là il
fait quelques bons coups la barre est
beaucoup plus dans le 5 bravo quoi
ah ça joue bien un côté
côté Jean-Christophe là
à droite à gauche et il va essayer
d'attendre faut savoir que tant que
toutes les pièces se protègent il peut
rien t'arriver contre quand tu joues
contre une dame tu peux pas dire double
attaque il peut y avoir des échecs ou
c'est tout mais bon ça ça va c'est pas
grave
et là il s'est pas mal recroquevillé
quand même
allez
alors là ça va être le problème
maintenant c'est qu'il va devoir cliquer
des deux côtés
normalement il devrait quand même la
perdre malheureusement mais enfin
malheureusement
tant mieux pour Yaro
les deux secondes c'est quand même très
différent des une seconde parcours ça te
laisse quand même envie tu souffles plus
tu souffles un peu ouais
une seconde tu es tout le temps dans le
dur une seconde tu remontes pas ouais tu
as pas le temps de voir
de voir le jour
ok mais le pion assis il a fait un bel
effort ici
il pourra pas arrêter les puntos des
deux côtés ça va gagner pour Hikaru
c'est trop passifs
[Musique]
maintenant donc
ça va être terminé
[Musique]
c'en est trop
juste de faire un petit tour bon cette
partie là elle a pas l'air passionnante
donc soit perdu ou il est en train de
perdre
un chat plusieurs vies cette vie je
crois ok
mais c'est quoi cette
bon a priori il s'en sort bien ça parce
qu'on voit ce qu'on a vu cru voir
bon on a la jauge
on a la jauge
au pire du pire au pire du pire
peut-être
à nouveau
relativement contente pour pour les
blancs qui pourtant un pion de moins
mais elles sont bien centralisés qui
attaque le pion E5
c'était quoi juste l'ouverture
mais les blondes doivent être un peu
mieux voilà paire de fou de colonnes
ouvertes bon c'est mieux 3 mais bon 2
c'est déjà quelque chose et avoir s'il
arrive à travailler cette position petit
à petit
c'est travaillable
je sais ce qui avait dit qui attaque en
plus un pion
et puis et puis monter le ressens un peu
les pièces rentrer les fous que tu
penses qu'ils ont mis sur l'ordinateur
de séviant une option pour essayer d'un
peu enlever la croix du roi adverse
il peut avec une souris
et le décaler 3 cases ce serait beau
quoi tu enlèves le roi et tu le dégage
quoi tu sors le chien
[Musique]
serait beau non avec des miettes de
couronnes qui traînent
ce serait beau qu'il ait une option
spéciale que pour lui quoi
c'est trop cool spécial quoi
il te défonce ton cavalier tiens dégage
connard
ce serait magnifique ça serait bien de
l'enlever toutes les pièces pourquoi que
le roi je pense qu'il va gagner c'est
bien je pense qu'il est plus fort que
que Sarine
il a plus des lots déjà de base
c'est un bon indicateur en général
après rompu au foot internet mais là
c'est pas des joutes internet tout à
fait habituelles femmes si joue sur
ordinateur mais ils sont dans une pièce
autre que leur domicile et ça des fois
c'est tu vois dans le confort que tu
peux avoir
c'est autre chose c'est pas le c'est pas
le même confort et je pense que du coup
c'est Vian est plus fort mais après à
confirmer tu as pas la même tapisserie
quoi déjà ça change on va avoir on verra
mais moi je mettrai une pièce sur Célian
[Musique]
j'ai pas trop aimé à 4 et moi non plus
mais en fait
en fait c'est marrant c'est peut-être
sur A3 il y avait un coup de con c'est
qu'il y a deux
billes mais pour refaire
et tu vois tu recommences avec les
machins
insupportable donc ouais bon ben c'est
la chance comme ça
[Musique]
c'est pas de bol pour séviant mais bon
il y a quand même peut-être la gagner
c'est bien joué
bah 25 secondes en face c'est pas énorme
donc pour le moment les résultats d'un
camura qui l'emporte contre Doodle sous
André Kid nulle Guiri un peu pleutre
contre Raja bof nul et ensuite donc la
dernière partie et juste après ben on se
la pose voilà jusqu'à 18h voilà et on
reprend et on reprend et on reprend à
18h
il va faire quoi
il veut quoi il veut x 3 en fait mais
c'est pour fermer l'autre
je l'aime pas trop quoi
4 et 3 2 il monte voir voilà que Ted
et si tu changes les cavaliers tu peux
aussi la gagner avec Laurent H5
éventuellement un défi
[Musique]
mais tu auras peut-être le cavalier en
B4 qui va t'empêcher avec à 5 de monter
ouais donc ils gardent le coup peut-être
il va faire le 3
ce X
franchement
puis après faut pas qu'il prenne sa
souris et qui la casse parce que sinon
il pourra plus jouer j'espère qu'il a un
touchpad au cas où
non mais il va pas faire nul quand même
non mais ok mais si tu fais nul là c'est
turbo pleutre pas fou c'est de toute
façon
[Musique]
aux autres échiquiers donc la règle est
la suivante maintenant pause jusqu'à
jusqu'à 18h on va vous laisser je vais
vous laisser avec avec le tableau des
scores et une perdeur quoi et une petite
musique et on se retrouve on se retrouve
sur les coups de 18h à tout de suite
tout le monde à tout de suite
[Musique]
problème sur l'audio ouais désolé il y a
un petit truc sur l'audio du coup c'est
Ikaru qui va avoir les noirs
je vais mettre les cames du bon côté
caméra de attends ouais voilà
donc ça va être doux qui va voir les
blancs
désolé j'ai eu un petit bug j'ai buggé
mais ça va le faire
et donc ça va être Hikaru
contre
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu en penses est-ce que tu
penses qu'il a une chance
Douda de
faire quelque chose
toujours sur une partie je veux dire il
est capable après sur le match
évidemment ça va être dur pour lui et
plus vite il avait réagi mieux ce sera
pour lui ça peut très vite à sens unique
sinon si tu veux je peux envoyer une
bande-annonce
attends
ah c'est magnifique la bande-annonce tu
vas kiffer
[Musique]
.com global Championship notre plus gros
tournoi de l'année et prêt à délivrer
son verdict
[Musique]
vous invite donc à suivre cette phase
finale epic en direct depuis Toronto et
Belgrade pour découvrir qui sera
couronné champion
[Musique]
alors les amis ça part j'ai coupé Fab la
bande-annonce parce que ça partait
au direct oui priorité au direct par
contre belle bande-annonce
j'espère qu'elle t'a fait plaisir
quand même ah bah oui j'étais en pause
encore donc c'est bien c'est magnifique
donc on a une petite catalane une petite
queue on va voir comment ça se trame
tout ça
ok
prépare éventuellement B5 pour
s'accrocher au Bion
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut aller le
récupérer du cavalier FD2 cavalier A3
cavalier BD il commence par A4 donc il
empêche B5
jouets en face donc bon il va regagner
ces quatre mais tu lâches un peu la
casse B4 aussi en contrepartie
[Musique]
donc c'est pas ton c'est pas ton rayon
c'est pas ton dada
toi
avec les Blancs non
j'aurais peut-être eu par hasard parce
que des fois je faisais des rétines des
KF3 g3c4 et ça arrive que les Noirs
jouent avec aussi ce machin fasse pas
grand chose et que tu fasses des quatre
et tu te retrouves dedans mais c'était
plutôt des catalanes quand je choisis ça
c'est à dire que si il me joue un
système un peu de merde à côté noir elle
me dit ok c'est une bonne catalane
mais sinon tu as jamais été genre de
Kata et pourquoi tu es pas tenté tu
aimes pas les fionketto quel est le j'ai
envie de dire pourquoi
non mais c'est plutôt que
je
joue plutôt E4 déjà et qui avait un côté
flemme à apprendre tout un nouveau pont
d'ouverture avec des quatre parce que
catalan ouais catalan tu fais sur les
grands vides mais si le mec touche une
benonine et c'est indienne une grue Feld
ou quoi bon bah tu dois aussi savoir que
je veux là-dessus donc il fallait
vraiment apprendre plein de nouvelles
variantes et bon moi je suis toujours
resté un peu feignant niveau ouverture
ça me permettait de jouer une autre
ouverture
c'était déjà beaucoup trop en fait voilà
c'est bon arrêtez de me faire jouer
aussi des quatre
j'ai même fait l'anglaise tu vois pour
rester un peu dans un truc donc bon KF3
c'est 4 4 plus si j'ai envie de faire
n'importe quoi je veux j'ai trop au
premier coup ou je sais pas quoi je suis
inquiet de la jauge sur ce cavalier 3
désolé Fab j'ai vu la jauge qui tout
d'un coup
prend du temps
il m'a pas l'air d'être super bien
préparéda un peu comme à son habitude
après ça on peut pas on peut pas
vraiment
pas vraiment savoir on peut pas juger
sur deux ouvertures parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça fait quelques mois
qui prend plus les échecs au sérieux
entre guillemets Jean-Christophe
j'avais même été étonné d'une
préparation pour les candidats j'aurais
dit un petit peu light
c'est vrai qu'il a pas
mieux avec de cette arme surprise déjà
et il a jamais trop bien pris cette
adversaire dans les ouvertures
ça c'est un point faible je te cache pas
que je m'attendais à mieux
je m'attendais à le voir un peu menaçant
il avait quand même fait une grosse
Coupe du Monde
tu disais ouais qui ciblait un peu ces
tournois tu parlais de tournoi ciblée je
reprends tes mots au bout d'un moment
non
je reprends pas tes mots mais quand même
il est dans le coup il est dans le coup
si je l'ai pas il est pas quoi voilà
ouais c'est un joueur de coup et je
m'étais dit bon il cible un peu ses
coups moi tu sais j'étais j'ai un peu
extrapolé mais en fait il est cible pas
du tout ouais c'est ça le truc ouais en
fait il subit le ciblage quoi c'est
c'est peut-être qu'il aurait bien aimé
pouvoir cibler les candidats mais que
bah il était pas il était pas trop dans
le coup et puis bah c'est comme si il me
fait penser
alors là complètement à notre sport
[Musique]
Pinot autour de français tu vois c'est
impression ici que ces étapes mais en
fait ouais non pas vraiment pression
c'est plus les étapes qui le cible en
fait ouais c'est ça c'est à tout moment
tu te dis il avait ciblé cette étape et
en fait il est pas dans les Chapais
non mais tu vois ça
se passe pas toujours comment on veut
non plus ou un Pierre Rolland
des fois tu es motivé tu fais la bonne
préparation machin et puis bon ben ça se
passe pas comme ça de vrai enfin comme
tu aurais aimé que ça se passe
on aimerait toujours que ça se passe
bien c'est sûr bon en fait si je suivais
de décider d'aller aujourd'hui je gagne
pour gagner on viendrait tous assez
souvent quoi bon après il y aura un
problème les deux décident en même temps
merde ce qui se passe en fait et c'est
là tout le problème c'est que les deux
joueurs décident de gagner
et
déçu au moins quoi alors des fois les
deux sont déçus alors là c'est c'est le
problème des échecs c'est que des fois
tu as deux déçus c'est pour ça que je
dis souvent cibler la nul voilà là
peut-être que tout le monde peut être
mais là encore il semble enfin au vu de
la jauge moi je me fie à la jauge Fab
Dieu les noirs et résolu leurs problèmes
d'ouverture complètement alors qu'il y a
des bouchons dans les oreilles oh là là
j'ai vu carreau qui s'est enlevé
de quoi
j'ai l'impression que le casque comprime
c'est ses oreilles et ça pourrait alors
je mets ça au conditionnel il sent pas
bien là du coup ça fait des
bourdonnements ouais voilà tu sais
peut-être ça a compris un peu la cire
dans l'oreille moi ça me le fait de
temps en temps et tu as des bouchons qui
peuvent se créer et je l'ai vu là tout
d'un coup enlever l'oreille gauche du
casque pour aller
mettre son auriculaire non non avec
l'auriculaire il est il serait allé avec
l'auriculaire peut-être essayer
d'enlever des poussières qui se qui se
comprimaient dans dans le conduit
auditif exactement Fabien
mais ça a l'air d'être passé en tout cas
il montre plus de signes d'énervement
avec cette petite alors peut-être pas
douleur mes petites gêne auditives pour
lui en tout cas ça fait des grimaces
quand même sur ce cavalier à deux
dans le dans le chat alors je ne pense
pas en tout cas
il a il a un bien joli casque Ikao
cavalier a de jouets
je crois pas qu'il y ait de public dans
le
dans les sages un petit peu essayer de
regarder le
les commentaires en anglais je n'ai pas
vu de de spectateurs
pour pour cette compétition
malheureusement est-ce que c'est que la
foule c'est pas déplacée ou que
carrément c'était pas prévu pour prévu
pour pour qui est des spectateurs Fabien
spectateurs sont sur Internet quoi c'est
ça les spectateurs sont sur internet
donc il a joué le coup B6 et on voit
cette jauge après B6 qui remonte je
n'aime pas du tout le coup un coup qui
n'a pas bien jaugé
alors pourquoi ça on va le découvrir
est-ce qu'il va trouver les coûts pour
faire redescendre cette
jauge vers le milieu ou pas c'est la
question qu'on se pose là enfin après
cinq minutes de partie et ce serait
important pour pour duda d'égaliser
immédiatement dans danser
alors une nul serait pas encore
rédhibitoire mais une défaite ce serait
déjà quasiment matchs
tout le monde descend donc là non bah
écoute on va voir là bon il a
éventuellement un petit avantage
peut-être à faire valoir
va falloir être précis mais bon bah déjà
le pion C4 peut être récupéré tu peux
gagner aussi la paire de fou en prenant
B4 d'abord peut-être donc avoir tu peux
enchaîner les deux en fait
je sais pas si c'est fou à 6 qui est
prévu Paris chaos pour s'activer quand
même ce fou viser vers eux et du coup
peut-être avec les ventes autre chose
avant c'est trop rien un coup peut-être
comme tourner un peu être envisageable
parce que tu as bien envie de faire quel
lieu cinq peut-être après
tu as créé un vis-à-vis etc
donc possible possible pour D1 mesdames
prends ces quatre
d'abord d'ailleurs et d'un Français 4
dans la foulée je trouve qu'il réfléchit
un peu trop longtemps Jean-Christophe
ouais il a déjà fait
tu as déjà fait le
coupé
ça serait bien que tu as le temps
réfléchir genre tout à l'heure à comment
agencer les pièces pour essayer de faire
une forteresse ou quoi et là tu es que
en train de jouer du réflexe donc
[Musique]
il a des bons réflexes après mais c'est
vrai que ça peut ne pas suffire bah non
mais des fois tu dois être précis quoi
tu peux cliquer
bizarre de pas aller quand même prendre
ce fou avant laisser en ville en bécane
j'aime pas trop
bon peut-être qu'il aime pas ramener le
pion à 5 en B4
ouais mais enfin c'est quand même un fou
quoi qu'il aurait pris sans trop
sourciller
en fait de pas d'avoir fait cavalier à
deux d'ailleurs enfin j'ai en fait tu
fais cavalier à deux
c'est quand même bon c'est aussi d'un
peu prendre ces quatre ou prendre B4
mais c'est quand même bizarre après
cavalier à deux de faire tu vois je sais
pas tu pouvais faire les deux coups que
tu menacées et en fait non des trompes
toi quoi
après c'est pas forcément mauvais
puisque les menaces sont la tente et
qu'elle reste dans la position mais
juste tu menaces un truc et que tu peux
le faire généralement autant le faire tu
étais là pour ça
ben complètement tu es venu tu es venu
pour et quoi
qui se prend la tête entre les mains
qui est en pleine en pleine réflexion le
joueur américain c'est problème auditifs
semble être maintenant derrière lui
Fabien
on va jouer
demain sans intervention extérieure
bizarre quoi mais tu vois du coup il
prend le
il a pris en des deux
oui ça me manque peut-être de cohérence
on va voir après les blancs bon c'est
pas si débile il va il va en prendre ces
quatre quand même un jour parce que la
force de le laisser vont le défendre et
puis tu vas jamais revoir et puis
peut-être faire quatre jours pour le
skate des cinq alors certes ça te ferme
un peu le fougereux ça te prend quand
même de l'espace et on va voir
ça assez terrible pour le moment
Douda qui semble pas avoir pris encore
la mesure du genre américain un peu
derrière dans le rythme un peu derrière
dans les ouvertures manque un peu de
cohérence il semble avoir du mal à
rentrer dans ce match Fabien ah mais
c'est pas évident de prendre la mesure
de
on en reviendra toujours est-ce que
c'est match ne sont pas trop court
finalement que 8 parties et c'est vrai
que si tu rates ton début un peu comme
là tu peux tu peux vite sortir
à force de pas le manger
après c'est position elles sont quand
même agréables à jouer même avec un pion
de moi tu as le centre ici avec le blanc
tu as la paire de fou tu as quand même
de beaux arguments à faire valoir et on
sait que maintenant on aime bien
avantage enfin compensation à long terme
c'est compensation à long terme c'est
catalan qui a été remis au goût du jour
par magne-nous scarlsen l'ex champion du
monde depuis deux jours il a
officiellement rendu son titre c'est
c'est écrit
donc là on a plus de champion du monde
on a plus de champion du monde
actuellement
je sais pas comment interpréter ça
en tout cas ils disent qu'il a rendu les
droits OK et pour pas cher en plus
gratuit
donc normalement je pense qu'à partir de
du moment où il a envoyé ce papier
officiel à la fille de en demandant
quelque part un solde de tout compte
c'est la fin du titre je pense que c'est
la fin du titre on a actuellement
on a quand même un champion du monde de
960 Fab actuellement à l'écran c'est
Karuna camera
champion du monde d'échec lui aussi qui
bat un Russe exactement comme le match
Fischer spati un titre de 960 rempli de
symboliques
Hikaru qui est maintenant l'équivalent
quelque sorte de Bobby Fisher
voilà
qui est son équivalent peut-être qui
pourra réussir peut-être même plus s'il
remporte si venez à défendre ce titre
ouais non on va défendre ce titre de 960
il serait double champion du monde
exploite que que n'a jamais réalisé
exactement
digne successeur et qui
reprend le flambeau à son propre jeu
ouais c'est beau c'est beau c'est beau
cavalier je sais pas j'ai l'impression
que que dudace patoche un peu dans la
semoule
en fait je veux bien croire qu'un ordi
peut-être est très heureux d'avoir un
pion de moi mais en fait je sais pas
enfin au bout d'un moment c'est énervant
il me demande quoi il est là en C4 il te
bloque ta colonne C il est chiant ce
pion qu'a fait
juste le prendre en fait et revenir
tu l'as pas récupéré
après les noirs peuvent pas non plus
faire grand-chose pour le moment mais
enfin je sais pas tu fais tout à 7 tours
des scènes B5
conditions ça va tourner
si tu as réussi à faire baisser 5 gants
de mon conditions ça va tourner
un petit coup de prépa pour éviter que
j'ai 4 et avancer non
ouais alors je sais pas pour arriver à
avancer mais pourquoi pas avec EF4 F4 F5
aussi un jour peut-être ou tu peux aller
en béton
en fait c'était une stratégie de laisser
le pion pour que tu le défendes regarde
tu perds du temps tu te décalages
tu défends ton pion de merde en C4 qui
te sert absolument à rien c'est une
stratégie
un peu des miettes quoi tiens regarde je
te donne des trucs vas-y avance
est-ce que c'est dans de bonnes
conditions
enfin c'est juste le bouffer en fait
voilà tu le bouffes bon les conditions
sont pas super que tu repères ta dame
bon
si c'est pour faire fou F1 faut penser 4
c'est changer le fou du champ keto pour
récupérer le pion et puis surtout que à
tout le monde tu peux te baisserico dès
que le Fou est parti donc
après le temps ça m'inquiète un peu en
penchant Christophe faut réussir à
apprendre des décisions un peu plus
rapidement je sais que c'est pas c'est
pas simple de jouer contre le
le célèbre streamer américain mais
à un moment donné il faut juste jouer un
coup quoi
du jeu d'échec
un peu ton tour
on verra quoi
puis si on prend puis on prend à E5 par
exemple
ou tu perds pas le pur à 5 ou enfin
bonne condition des conditions qui te
vont bien quoi bah c'est que quand ça
marche quoi
après ouais bon peut-être qu'il y a un
truc qui bon il a fait je trouve un truc
qui peut peut-être l'embêter c'est E5
des noirs
pour bloquer un peu pourquoi pas ramener
le crédit
du coup bon après je sais pas si il y a
ou compte faire ce 5 ou pas ou je vais
faire des tours D8 et compagnie mais
voilà il fait tourner donc bon on
imagine qu'il veut faire F4 maintenant
voilà ça évite les G4 donc du coup je
dois préparatoire et on commence à
avancé la marée ça permet aussi
peut-être de faire dame F2 et G4 si
besoin ou
peut-être F5 à un moment enfin on va
voir ça lui donne pas mal d'options
exception en tout cas je pense qui Caro
il va envoyer un B5 à un moment donné
ouais il va falloir réagir un moment
parce que si tu fais trop rien
[Musique]
ça va ça va dérouler
visuellement voilà en fait tu tapes là
tu tapes là t'empêche laisser 5
t'empêche ça t'empêche le 5
du couvre H4 F4 tu fais G4
donc ça fait multifonctions
en fait
bon on va voir il a une position pas
trop mal quand même
début je mets pas trop son truc de
parpainte C4 mais bon il est obtenu
quand même pas mal de jeux de l'autre
côté
il peut la gagner ça là ce serait bien
pour le suspense du match qui pour moi
c'est une finale avant l'heure
franchement c'est ouais c'est vrai que
enfin si c'est un doigt en pleine forme
oui
ce qu'on a déjà vu faire avant des beaux
trucs sur sur Internet et des mini grish
should par exemple
il y a quelques
confinement ou c'est peut-être devenu un
petit peu plus dur c'est coup d'éclat
ouais mais du coup tu vois c'était déjà
beau c'est quelque chose beau joueur et
et de le battre sur un match en trois
heures c'est pas rien et puis bah Douda
avait 3-4 ans de moins donc c'était
vraiment un jeune joueur en devenir et
on disait ouais
et on peut pas dire qu'il est pas
confirmé en fait il a maintenu son
niveau mais il a pas
en fait c'est pas en fait on attendait
il a pas confiance dans le sens où on
attendait justement que ce soit un
premier pas voilà en fait il a juste
maintenu le niveau quoi
ça serait genre un mec comme cimer au
tennis et puis qui te fait que des
cartes et demi de Grand Chelem bah t'es
déjà contente ou c'est pas mal mais tu
te dis qu'en fait tu le verrais bien
gagner quand je t'aime un jour et puis
si dans cinq ans il est encore là à
faire des cars et tout ça tu dis bon ok
c'est bien ça bon niveau tu finis
peut-être 8e mondiale ou quoi mais tu
espérais plus quoi
c'est un peu ça
il fait c'est un 45 ça donne la case des
5 faut toujours faire attention et d'un
autre côté le cavalier est parti il y a
l'autre il faut y aller il peut faire ça
c'est un si peu se replacer les
cavaliers de manière un peu bizarre
après ouais donc 5 tu donnes tu donnes
aux quatre en échange et éventuellement
des 6/7 pour faire des combines
ok bon on va voir ça devient tout d'un
coup beaucoup plus concret
comme tout
maintenant ça donne un plan comme roi H2
tours géant fou F3 et bim quoi
il avait très peur que les Blancs le
fassent eux-mêmes F5 il voulait pas voir
ça vous voulez pas se s’écraser avec F5
F6 ou F5 Tour Eiffel c'est des plans
comme ça donc il s'est dit ok je bloque
et tout ce qui espère c'est qu'il y a un
gprp maltime et qui puisse planter un
cavalier là et tenir sur les caisses
blanches avec des blocus mais bien sûr
Douda va pas le faire il prend F5 ça
montre lequel il peut pas prendre ou
alors
j'ai enfin que tu as mis tout ton truc
en place tu mets la semaine des G5 il y
aura plus H5 et tu peux ouvrir
donc ouais ça a pas l'air con c'est
juste qu'il faut jouer un peu plus vite
parce que là c'est un plan entre
guillemets stratégique et tu as
quasiment tes trois prochains coups
ouais je vois pas trop
ou pas il a passé 5 tours je trouve que
c'est très bizarre mais
bon ok pourquoi pas je sais pas pourquoi
ce stade de coup mais si c'est pour
faire
je sais pas où j'ai trois H4 et glisser
deux tours pourquoi pas
ok donc toi et fuite c'est bon on
maintient peut-être du un coup de dames
un coup de F3 un truc
on nous dit honnêtement en tout cas
vainqueur de la Coupe du Monde vice
champion du monde de Blitz les candidats
c'est mieux que ce que j'en attendais
très franchement moi j'en attendais même
un peu plus en réalité de ce joueur
moi je le voyais bien s'installer
durablement dans le dans le top 10 top 5
mondial en fait et là il est à 27 35
alors il marche il a des coudes mais moi
je le voyais ouais plus stable plus
mettre les gants en danger plus
fréquemment en fait
bon à sopalmas je pense qu'il a déjà
battu Carlsen quelquefois en partie
lente donc c'est pas mal
et comme je dis c'est plutôt un joueur
de coup d'éclat en fait c'est pas il a
pas la stabilité
je le voyais vraiment au dessus d'un
rapport tout quoi alors que finalement
se ressemble il s'est
c'est ça plus dans les premiers rôles
voilà je préfère quand même le palmarès
de Duba parce que pour moi la victoire
en Coupe du monde en éliminant Carlson
en 2006 elle est quand même très belle
et c'est c'est un très gros titre de
battre Carlson surtout qu'il avait
éliminé avec la manière dans un tournoi
Carlson avec clairement ciblé dans son
année ouais donc ça je trouve que c'est
vraiment un gros truc mais donc je le
mets un peu au dessus mais oui je le
voyais quand même au moins stable à 27
60 tu vois et
menaçant dans n'importe quelle grande
chaise tour dans au candidats aussi
ouais je le voyais quand même un peu
plus dans ce dans ce registre
après c'est quand même pas fini mais oui
faudra faudrait qu'il ait le un petit
coup de collier là qui le remette dans
le bon peloton quoi elle est un peu dans
le peloton débattu
il fait un peu pensé un petit mot piste
on peut le peloton Navara quoi
ouais il est loin quoi il est loin après
il y a quand même du beau monde aux
alentours de son élo c'est pas c'est non
mais c'est déjà dur en fait de faire ça
c'est même pas c'est pas pour critiquer
c'est juste que c'est un genre très
talentueux très fort et que tu tombes
toujours beaucoup pour ce genre de
joueur
qui soit qui joue les premiers rôles aux
candidats et qui menacent de s'y
qualifier plusieurs fois en tout cas on
verra avec ce nouveau cycle quelles
seront les forces en présence mais dans
cette partie il semble mettre quand même
en danger icaruna camera c'est rassurant
quand au contenu global du match
ça s'en va la gauche
bon après le coup elle absurde enfin je
sais pas pourquoi mais
[Musique]
on va voir on va voir s'il fait la
différence en tout cas bon il est
toujours comme c'est deux minutes devant
la pendule et ça peut jouer ça peut
jouer carreau qui peut te trouver un
petit truc pour un petit truc à la
Houdini sortir de après
en cavalier prend et fouger 2 et ça
s'envole l'autre en plus qui est pas
forcément le truc logique quoi donc
ça c'était logique mais ouais c'est con
qui réfute autant pour jouer l'écologie
mais la sensation que c'est des coups tu
les joues dans un ordre ou dans l'autre
après c'est sûr qu'il a de prendre une
peau de banane mais là je crois que
c'était pas le cas de figure où ça
pouvait réellement arriver et il a
peut-être jeté deux trois minutes à la
poubelle qui pourrait être cruciale en
fin de partie bah oui oui
personnellement
tout en place pour avoir G5 H5 et bien
bloqué et pouvoir réagir donc ok il va
se mettre en place pour les sacrifier la
barre on va voir le taux un oranger de
et il va construire calculer le G5 et
j'y prends F pourquoi pas faire cade
[Musique]
il faut se bouger là de toute façon
cette tour elle a plus rien à faire sur
la colonne des en réalité
une bye tu vois tu peux aussi calculer
des G5 déjà la même si j'y crois pas
trop mais oui
c'est des cas de figures où tu pourrais
casse quoi dire avoir des sacrifices de
dames mais là je vois pas dans quel cas
mais même des dames prends H6 dans
certains cas assez incroyables peuvent
marcher avec
bien trop placer
pour aller retaper sur la diagonale se
met en face du roi
mais bon il va falloir percer la
capacité ou maintenant c'est pas fait
bah il est mieux ça c'est ok on le voit
la jauge confirme mais ok il a tout bien
agglutiné là-bas et c'est pas simple il
a pas de maths pour le moment
et en fait quand c'est comme ça ce
serait bien d'avoir le temps inversé
soyez carreaux qui doivent suer à
chercher s'il y a pas une combine qui
lui tombe sur la tête à chaque fois et
que du coup tu m'appelles la pression un
moment bon ben il va perdre tout seul
parce qu'il va te laisser un truc là
et voilà tu peux pas trouver de la
pression au temps
tu peux même pas du tout
quand tu as une minute 24 tu peux plus
tourner en rond et rien faire c'est plus
possible en fait pas plus le temps
d'être malin et d'avoir des petits coups
marins on va voir on va voir si réussi à
percer
mais bon en tout cas il est arrivé à
créer une position intéressante et donc
même pas du match peut être pas mal ça
lui donne une ouverture où il sait qu'il
peut essayer de creuser parce que ça
écarte réparer le truc quoi
ouais et puis même globalement juste que
j'aime bien c'est que c'est plus qu'une
ouverture c'est un type de position
à un moment
c'est une tête de bon coup
ça réellement une tête de bon coup
ouais
il faisait plus grand chose le pion C4
il sert il sert plus à rien après tu
peux peut-être faire juste dame 2 ici
non
quelque sorte mesdames 2 il veut
peut-être qu'il y ait des cinq
et là tu vois c'est là que ça ça le fait
pas 45 secondes pour pour
Jean-Christophe
comme prévu
et du coup tu prends il reprend il se
sécurise le pion tu peux pas prendre ces
quatre il y a ton four en l'air il va
faire pousser un truc j'imagine ouais
mais est-ce que c'est pas
mais peut-être ça à ce moment-là et que
ça devient pas trop clair mais bon ok
c'est quand même pas mal il y avait un
coup peut-être simple je vais vite
c'était tourgé trois juste en fait tu
t'enlèves
mais tu vois le tour qui le coup qu'il a
peut-être perdu avec ton des deux tours
G2 au lieu de faire genre tourger un
tour j'ai trois tours géant pas se
mettre directement la tour bien bon
après les Caro aurait probablement pas
fait ça à ce moment-là mais quand même
c'est des petits détails tu vois que ta
tour elle est mieux mais bon il aurait
pas eu de la F2 ok on peut aller bouffer
ces quatre j'imagine ouais mais c'est là
qu'il te faut plus de temps parce que
contre Ricardo on est d'accord quand
même que dans la tête même pour des
joueurs du calibre de Douda tu prends un
peu plus de temps pour jouer des coups
comme dame français 4 contre un tel
ou deux fois plus voilà faut prendre de
la tour ah il y a une idée
c'était sûr qu'il avait une idée
d'enflure
c'était sûr eh mais bon c'est
obligatoire il en a toujours une de plus
ah c'était malin ce dame D8
du coup ouais il a la structure qui
voulait avec les Noirs après bon tu
restes avec des faiblesses partout F2
pour focaliser et tenir cette case H4 ça
peut être important puis on voit ce qui
avait dit OK
[Musique]
elle est terrible la position pour les
Noirs mais bon plus que 21 secondes pour
Jean-Christophe
twenty one seconds for Jean-Christophe
comme ils doivent être en train de dire
là sur le stream en anglais en américain
ils doivent être comme des fous furieux
là
les gens qui savent cas sa position C5
ça va
et carreau qui a plus qu'une 10 ça
commence à suer pour le joueur américain
c'est un peu la cata
il menace cavalier F6 quand même je
pense je sais pas s'il y a une tactique
qui termine la partie derrière mais
ça peut être malin
il va aller bouffer B5 qui a validé des
6 bah c'est pas con non plus hein ça
protège le pion maintenant
ça peut pas être con
il est en train de digérer le pion de
plus là et après il va essayer d'envoyer
B6 je suppose enfin pour ça il est
toujours pas de contre-jupe KO mais il
va peut-être te faire un G5 à un moment
un truc un arrache comme ça allez il
faut cliquer
j'ai peur que le temps lui manque
tellement dur pour tricot pour l'instant
je gère bien en tout cas mais oui enfin
il y a plus de 12 secondes donc comme on
disait tout à l'heure il finit qu'à
partir avec que des réflexes et donc
c'est un monde très précis tu peux pas
enfin ça sera le hasard quoi
c'est la bonne nouvelle ouais mais après
il est plus à l'aise car vous quand même
allez il faut jouer plus de 7 secondes
d'AMS et 6 un peu pleutre
Ikaru c'est un spécialiste ça de te
pousser un couple de te tenter de te
tenter dans la poterie de te la tenir il
a piéger Baki plus d'une fois et c'est
souvent un truc qui fait le problème
c'est que là en fait il se fait plus
Malcher là ça va durer longtemps
maintenant alors c'est sûr tu es une
fille avec un peu plus c'était bien mais
il lui fait ça spécial il menace c'est
typique typique et Caro
c'est en fait tu fous le bordel et après
tu donnes un backdoor qui est qui permet
d'échanger les pièces un genre de truc
psychologique
il est presque il menace pas vraiment
matte encore c'est chauffable ton G2
attends j'ai deux c'est le coup de
l'ordi c'est hyper fort
j'ai un c'est moins fort allez tourger
deux
obligations
en fait il va juste la perdre en fait il
se fait intercepter le fou
ça a l'air d'être un coup tellement à
côté peut-être ça aurait péter
après c'est plutôt lui qui menace quand
même Fab plus que 6 secondes pour Yaro
j'ai 5 cases de fuite
il se barre avec le roi il monte
immédiatement et là il y a tout qui
devient faible il y a trois qui va
tomber et oui retourne aide mais mérité
quand même parce que il a il a trop
réfléchi à des moments où il était pas
obligé et il rate une opportunité en or
mais là maintenant il a il a deux pions
moins à moins d'une arnaque légendaire
une petite petite fourchette un petit
machin mais bon
son cavalier était tellement mal placé
il faut qu'il réussisse à le ramener
allez là il va peut-être y arriver enfin
allez le cheval allez le chaud il sort
de l'écurie
il est dans le trait dur il est dans le
trait dur bah ce serait dommage parce
que ce serait quasiment fin de match
quoi et c'est un peu bon sur le papier
le seul match intéressant du premier
tour quand même enfin c'est celui que tu
as vraiment envie de suivre genre
largement au-dessus des autres
à moins d'être supporters d'un des
autres mais
c'est les deux plus beaux joueurs du
tournoi d'entrée qui s'affrontent donc
c'est oui c'est sûr que c'est dommage si
ce machin est déjà plié en fait
on va être supporter de Douda mais ouais
il va pas la tenir et surtout qu'il
était tellement bien ouais
[Musique]
et oui
il est encore là-bas F7 à faire
un peu penser à crasso en attaque en
fait ce cavalier non mais grâce
[Musique]
c'est notre attaquant
c'est dur c'est peut-être pintor
tu sais pas quand tu vas gagner quoi du
coup
c'est comme ça enfin on connaît l'animal
mais jamais tu vas gagner quand tu vas
gagner jamais alors Niall Sarine il a
des blancs il se fait il est pas trop
bien non on va on va mettre les noms on
va suivre un petit peu ce match après
bon il te tente un peu contre
mais il y a le Pinter de Samse viande
qui qui pour l'instant il n'a pas encore
pris le carton rouge donc il est là
farine
un peu dans le dur
pintor le joueur stephanois de la SS
rompu au jeu de Ligue 2 Fabien
je sais pas quoi dire rompu quand même
il est assez exceptionnel quand même
c'est vraiment
il est exceptionnel quoi les deux trois
matchs que j'ai vu c'est
il m'a pas trop impressionné
faire les efforts
et plus de temps
bon ça fait beaucoup de défauts tout ça
pourrait
marrant priori en portugais ça veut dire
peintre on nous dit que
mais bon
et dans les autres parties il y a déjà
ah il y a ouais c'est ça qui a battu
André King quand même
mais ça va tu peux se passer pas mal de
choses j'ai l'impression ouais moi aussi
ouais ça refait nul ouais ouais ça c'est
bien ça peut faire 8 minutes ça devient
une petite armée
et là on a on a donc cette position
qui est complètement gagnante pour les
Noirs là là la question c'est ce qui va
la conclure enfin il y a pas grand chose
à dire c'est qualité
ses qualités de moins on voit que toutes
les pièces noir sont bien placées mais
c'est jamais facile de gagner une partie
du jeu d'échec faut toujours faire un
effort jouer un coup de plus faire un
effort de plus
c'est jamais simple
on va carrément pu jouer mvl en ce
moment je crois qu'il a un peu ouais il
a un peu
équipe ouais
belle compétition aussi Fabien ouais
magnifique
ça concurrence peut-être le global
event quoi
à tout moment voilà faut la mettre au
fond comme dans le chat bah ça ouais
c'est complètement gagnant enfin c'est
[Musique]
quand même envie de terminer la partie
maintenant et tout de suite
madame 8
mais ça c'est le truc qui meurt le plus
aux échecs c'est positions en fait ça
doit être complètement gagnant et c'est
pas normal en fait que tu dois encore
réfléchir juste oui c'est insupportable
ça devrait pas exister quand tu fous un
cheval un truc et tout d'un coup
mais tu as entendu ça où
ouais c'est maso qui me parle parce
qu'il a bien joué donc on en parlait
pendant la Coupe d'Europe des Clubs donc
il y a un petit mois mais c'était
toujours pas clair quoi jusqu'au mon
sèche chaque année quand sont les dates
tout le monde bon ceux qui veulent jouer
ils se gardent un peu les dates de libre
mais il y a rien officiel mais c'est
dans un mois donc
un mois et demi
c'est quand même relativement bientôt
c'est pas sûr qu'il a gagné en fait il
est en train de péter un plomb c'est en
train de le saouler
très bien j'ai
ça très bien aussi
[Musique]
elle a l'air sympa quand même
des 7 échec encore
propre Sam Sam qui prend la tête dans ce
match qui domine la tête les épaules
parce que de ce qu'on a vu de la
première partie il était mieux
la deuxième il la gagne c'est assez
sympa on va je vais ajouter un œil là je
peux une monte de 8 parce que quand même
là c'est on a on a on a un peu de temps
on va faire quand même une belle pause
attention mais
comme ça on va pouvoir vous dire
là tu peux aller sur feed ou pas
est-ce qu'ils disent quelque chose
calendar world events c'est World Evans
on va voir Championship il a annoncé du
25 au 30 mais il y a les règles
c'est bien ici
un classement
[Musique]
de Beach champion du monde de rapide
vous encaissez 120000 dollars et c'est
dur ouais c'est dur et si vous gagnez le
Global Championship conçu actuellement
c'est 200000 dollars donc c'est un
tournant il y a nettement plus d'argent
nanana technique attends il y a la
cérémonie d'ouverture les jours les
machins mais il y a pas le lieu non non
non non
ou ça devait être je sais pas où et à
cause du Quick on est en Pologne enfin
il y a eu un truc
ça faisait pas être Kazakhstan ou
[Musique]
je sais plus exactement
donc ils peuvent te refaire le coup tu
vois si je commentais l'événement c'est
4000 balles
[Musique]
presse officer mais c'est à peu près ça
quand tu commentes
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal d'habitude
je le fais gratuit sur ma chaîne
et j'ai pas les images
mais faut que ce soit eux qui te nomme
peut-être voilà par exemple comme on
appelle le candidats féminins ils disent
qu'il y a pas assez d'audience et ça se
joue à Monaco c'est mon club en fait et
il demande à des personnes locales de
commenter mais ouais j'ai pas réussi à
ou alors tu fais trop d'audience
ils ont pas changé depuis le 1er janvier
2018 il faudrait peut-être changer ça
quand même on se rend peut-être un petit
peu contre là en ce moment que ça suffit
pas là si c'est les mêmes qu'en 2018
c'est un problème attention mais donc
quoi il y a pas le lieu il y a les dates
mais il y a pas le lieu bon ok donc
comme je te dis c'est priori ils vont
arriver à l'organiser peut-être que même
ils te diront une semaine avant ou c'est
mais
champion du monde amateur à Malte je
crois ouais ouais ça doit être un beau
tournoi
qui a été gagné par un
kazaki peut-être
en moins de 2000 c'est quoi qui ont tout
pris en fait c'est magnifique trois
cases beaucoup trop fort
mon gueule
moins de 2000 ouais mon gars il y a un
français qui a fini le troisième Asaf à
la star
moins de 17
00 mongol il y a un fidèle qui a pris la
deuxième place
une belle compétition franchement ça
devrait aller jouer en fait nous on
serait très heureux
laissez-moi tranquille quoi
en plus il y avait les faire de faire
assez beau quoi
je suis je suis avocat je suis juriste
j'habite à Malte enfin bravo Monsieur
très intéressant comme personnage
bravo il a un très beau t-shirt lui là
[Musique]
c'est Nicolas
197 joueurs 51 fédération
à 30 km au nord du du de l'aéroport
c'est magnifique
[Musique]
non mais peut-être que bon je dis ça
comme ça mais imagine on organise un
truc où on va suivre des
des corbeaux ou des requins on va dire
qui veulent aller jouer ça et on
organise une excursion où on va les
coacher pendant ce temps-là
surtout à Malte ça a l'air d'être une
belle île ça
peut être intéressant quoi comme terre
de streamer en plus Malte
en fait c'est très beau quoi et puis en
plus tu rencontres des avocats des
machins enfin des très très bien quoi
enfin on a décidé de rester en fait ça
nous a beaucoup plu si ça devrait rester
pour la météo le climat
c'est l'avocat qui a du temps libre qui
m'a conseillé là il a dit qu'il y a un
très bon climat si regarde il fait très
beau il a une peau très douce et tout va
bien quoi
qui me parle
il fait un devis et tout là c'est
un volet j'ai volé qui se sont cassés
bon là c'est vrai que tu aimerais bien
savoir combien ça va te coûter quoi
il est très heureux
on fait la petite pause
on peut faire la petite pause si tu veux
13 minutes tu vois on fait une petite
pause de 10 minutes
[Musique]
et on est de retour
les amis
pour la
troisième partie du match et qui
pourrait déjà sonner le Cloud des
maigres espoirs restants
[Musique]
on va voir
j'ai fait n'importe quoi avec les noms
je me mélange à chaque fois les blancs
et les noirs
on va voir on va voir si réussi à
lutter Douda en tout cas il est il est
pas bien
non mais c'est dur c'est un coup au
moral parce que bon la première tu joues
pas très bien tes dominé tu perds bon
c'est la vie deuxième bonne partie tu es
bien tu dois gagner et en fait tu es
quand même autour de toi du coup
du coup
voilà tu as déjà deux points de retard
et tu sais pas trop comment tu vas finir
par gagner une partie quoi
comment gagner
la rigueur tu perds pas tu faisais nul
ouais ça te mettait du pommeau tu dis
bon ok fais chier mais bon allez
prochaine fois je joue un peu plus vite
ça va le faire
c'est dur
[Musique]
en fait quel visage il va nous
offrir
Lionel Jospin
ça devient de plus en plus fort et amis
terrible
c'est un peu étonnant parce que j'ose
pas me Verseau pas qualifié pour mais il
aurait pu un jospermes
4e ouais ça aurait j'ose même c'est un
joueur qui pourrait dans le dans le
futur ce qualifier pour ces tournois
gratin gratin quoi
internet j'ose même
probablement dans le dans le top top
mondial sur Internet
c'est qui en fait enfin son nom
[Musique]
mais bon peut-être qu'il a éclore
récemment moi je joue aussi donc je te
croise moins quoi
elle a pas vraiment écloré sa maman je
crois fable mais
Martin Alcantara mais c'est un très très
gros joueur internet spécialisé sur sur
Internet
et vraiment très fort parce que
tu as même quand même qu'en gris Chuck
et tout c'était remis à jouer sur
internet tu vois 25 97
il a 23 ans
OK et voilà peut-être qu'il va venir
vivre un peu en Europe pas mal de
joueurs le font tu crois qu'il est parti
aux États-Unis alors attends je suis un
peu étonné j'ai l'impression qu'il
je sais pas pourquoi ouais non ça a pas
l'air de jouer en tout cas moi
normalement j'ai les parties qui se
lancent automatiquement
on attend ok mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il joue alors attends c'est peut-être
un bug c'est possible
donc on va
ce que je les suis en fait donc
normalement ouais non il joue pas
apparemment
et un petit retard la pose un peu plus
longue que prévu
ça peut arriver ouais
c'est des belles poses après
c'est bien ça donne vraiment le temps
aux joueurs de
se reposer
c'est vrai que ça manque il y avait les
jours de repos déjà dans dans les
tournois et c'est vrai que cet ajout de
pause quand même quelque chose de
positif pour que les joueurs aient
vraiment le temps de se remettre les
idées en place et nous offre un beau
spectacle
là peut-être quelque chose qu'on peut un
peu regretter finalement ce tournoi ce
qui était pas toujours de pause entre
les tours ce que je me disais
effectivement j'ai pensé la même chose
que toi c'est-à-dire qu'elle est quart
de finale qui sont lundi et bah le
mercredi et jeudi et il aurait pu vendre
une journée de repos voilà bon tu as des
belles demi-finales samedi dimanche bon
lundi tu souffles et puis tu finis un
mercredi un jour idéal pour faire un
tournoi c'est bien
[Musique]
notre plus gros tournoi de l'année et
prêt à délivrer son vernis
[Musique]
de prendre de l'ampleur depuis son
lancement mais voyons des milliers de
joueurs s'affrontés pour tenter de se
tailler une part du gâteau d'un million
de dollars
8 finalistes exceptionnels ont en
découdre dans une ultime bataille afin
de déterminer qui remportera les 200 000
dollars premiers au vainqueur et le
premier titre de champion de chasse.com
de l'histoire avec encore debouts dans
l'arène 6 anciens candidats et l'un des
meilleurs juniors du monde la phase
finale s'annonce palpitante alors j'ai
augmentant la durée des matchs est aussi
revue à la hausse les cuit parties
disputés en 15 + 2 au lieu de 4 encore
plus d'excitation et de rebondissements
sont attendus
icarunakamura Diane Christophe Douda
Wesley Sow Dimitri André itine taille
muraja BOV anniv
Samse n'ont plus qu'un objectif en tête
je vous invite donc à suivre cette au
final épique en direct depuis Toronto et
Belgrade pour découvrir qui sera
couronné champion
[Musique]
leces.com global Championship notre plus
gros tournoi de l'année et prêt à
délivrer son verdict
[Musique]
désolé à la bande-annonce qui a fait une
boucle mais
mais la partie qui a toujours pas repris
peut-être qu'ils veulent il voudrait
mettre la bande-annonce en boucle je
sais pas pourquoi là ça prend un peu un
peu de retard après c'est pas c'est pas
très grave
les joueurs ont bien le temps de se
reposer au moins
ça c'est quand même important Fabien
ouais
ils vont vraiment être en pleine forme
et c'est la voix de Samy que vous pouvez
entendre dans le dans la bande-annonce
allez ça rejoue alors attends oui alors
en fait on est complètement
en fait je suis complètement décalé avec
les caméras c'est ça en fait je sais pas
pourquoi je fais que de m'inverser avec
les cames
c'est dans l'autre sens en fait j'avais
mis dans le bon sens dans le premier
temps et après je l'ai retourné pour une
raison complètement débile
c'est avec les blancs avec les blancs
ils ont changé d'ouverture ouais bah n'a
pas répété la pétrole C6 pour défendre
l'option E5 et c'était l'espagnol et
Douda je choisis de jouer
une berlinoise
et voilà
est-ce que tu as trouvé une tour une
date pour ton tour
il y a personne qui m'a contacté
de toute façon ce sera pas avant avril
ça c'est sûr
sont pas intéressés pour l'organiser
donc on va faire un truc de notre côté
OK
écoute ce serait dommage de faire un
tournoi il y a du monde qui marche c'est
quand même toujours triste
on accueille qui connaisse qui fait ça
peut turbodrome
je pense aussi je connais pas mais je
connais pas non plus mais il joue tout
tempo donc tu donnerais pas F2 tempo si
tu connaissais pas
peut-être d'autres choses qu'une
berlinoise pour essayer de mettre en
difficulté
de s'embêter oh non monsieur
c'est très bien enfin
il a match il a match quasi perdu entre
guillemets
pourquoi tu vas t'embêter
non je sais pas bon tu peux encore y
croire en fait tu vois toute façon il te
sens plus
dans un vrai tournoi tu peux te dire ok
je peux en forme je vais pas te défoncer
mes points et l'eau et
c'est vrai ça
[Musique]
c'est la même chose non non tu as raison
tu as raison j'avais pas j'avais oublié
ce facteur parce que comme il joue quand
même en semi réel et tout c'est vrai que
j'ai oublié le facteur que ça compte pas
pour le vélo donc oui tu en a absolument
rien à [ __ ] en fait
donc tu peux encore tenter
les carreaux est très tranquille
après peut-être qu'il connaît pas dedans
ah non bah là on dirait à peu près
donc pourquoi pas
tu as déjà un pion de plus donc tu rends
ton
positif tu fais que rendre
donc
moi je ferai fou aussi peut-être
tu veux garder ton de plus
enfin tu veux prendre je me fais des
pions doublés je suis enfin je suis
content en fait
moi je m'en fous aussi ce serait mon
coup
donc c'est quoi
très heureux de trouver si c'est un
genre j'ai l'impression d'être à deux
doigts de gagner alors je ferai moins
bien mais mais je serais très confiant
en tout cas ce serait clairement mon
option principale
et toi
le patron ce que j'aurais mais oui
priori tu as l'impression de solutionner
tes problèmes en faisant ça
j'ai l'impression que tu les solutions
d'ailleurs
là tu peux envisager que la morale
[Musique]
si tu reprends F7 échange tout tu
ramènes ton fils
ici
je veux garder ton plan de plus et faire
fout ici analyser
[Musique]
est-ce que tu fais à 5 ou pas
ah regarde d'un côté tu as le temps mais
d'un côté il peut te faire à 5 jours
mais sinon tu fais quoi tu fais cavalier
F5
[Musique]
après c'est une approche je sais pas
intéressante mais bon c'est bizarre de
jouer avec un pion de moins comme ça
pour des trucs qui sont pas évident
[Musique]
c'est pas évident c'est pas clair
c'est pas clair comme position Naka qui
réfléchit qui a été vite fait à 5 ou X7
ça va être joué de façon il a pas le
choix
rien de concret avec les blancs mais le
truc c'est que il a tout l'espace
et les noirs sont un peu ligotés la tour
à 8 peut pas rentrer en jeu qui va aller
aussi
c'est peut-être un coup
mais moi il y a peut-être cavalier 7
rois 7 H3 x H5 G4 fougères 6
ce genre de choses qui Épron j'ai 6 roi
prend ça a l'air de tenir mais il y a
peut-être un truc dans
dans ces ordres là de coups qui peut
gêner
donc ici c'est quand même un coup mais
j'aurais une mauvaise
un mauvais a priori sur le coup on peut
voir ce que l'ordinateur donne
alors pas du tout j'étais à côté de la
plaque l'ordi donne fous prend H6
et sur pion prend cavalier prend qui est
étranger 4 et il y a pas faut prendre F5
intermédiaire du coup
j'étais à côté de la blague mais après
la deuxième ligne c'était quand même ma
ligne je crois sa deuxième ligne c'était
quand même cette idée là je crois
cavaliers 7 h 3 fois H5 G4 fou G6 qui
est rangé 6
un truc dans ce temps là ça allait pas
non plus
la position pour les Noirs déjà
bizarre non
tu es déjà mal au temps et tu peux plus
bouger tes pièces et tu as peut-être te
prendre 3 heures pratique
c'était le meilleur objectif mais si
c'est super chiant à jouer tu vas faire
5 minutes par coup dans trois coups tu
as plus de temps quoi donc
on sera peut-être la 3-0 autant de zéro
c'est déjà 99% de chance de gain pour
Nakamura voir même un petit peu plus bon
les 99 autant 3-0 on est on est sur deux
99,9
mis à part un problème de santé
une chiasse tu vois qui lui prend tout
d'un coup et là ça pourrait ça pourrait
tourner
ce serait étonnant
après c'est vite arrivé un sushi qui
passe mal un machin et tout d'un coup
c'est ton jeune c'est ton jeune
exactement encore qu'on peut quand même
jouer même avec la chasse tu peux quand
même réussir à jouer
tu cours vite
ouais mais après tu perds quand même
beaucoup de minéraux et pour la
concentration et pour la force ça peut
ça peut être dérangeant mais bon
ça peut ça tu peux quand même jouer et
si tu mets une 3-0
malgré ça tu peux tu peux quand même
réussir à défendre tes chances
mais en tout cas il est en difficulté
non non tu peux tu peux jouer les gens
d'ici du véhicule bah ça a du t'arriver
enfin
j'imagine ouais pas trop souvent non
plus quand même ouais mais ça a quand
même du temps
[Musique]
par contre
en gueule de bois plus dur
ça t'est déjà arrivé de jouer en gueule
de bois
et il y a le cavalier 4 qui est bon
aussi
bon comme quoi faut prendre ce que
j'arrivais pas à trouver c'était pas si
facile
puisque Douda après 6 minutes de
réflexion de l'as pas vu
et ça va être ça va faire encore Punto
moi gueule de bois aussi mais pas en
partie longue
en partie longue ça va être dur
d'écouté
je pense qu'en partie je j'ai une bonne
chance de le trouver quand même
fougères bon il faut quand même 5 que le
problème c'est assez forcé quoi j'ai HF
e machin
tu as du jeu mais après si vous préférez
tu peux préférer
au blanc cette finale mais bon tu mets
2-0 tu as une finale ou tu as un frérot
là tu es quand même très heureux il est
heureux de tout là
il a la chiasse il s'arrête pour chier
sur le bas-côté ce qui lui coûte du
temps mais sans conséquence
eh mais tu es obligé d'aller chier dans
ces cas-là et
c'est vrai si tu peux faire autrement de
toute façon ouais ouais ça peut être
ça peut être un peu un peu un peu gênant
autant que ça va être dur de jouer avec
une cystite
quoi que tu es c'est pénible ou un
calcul rénal
non mais tu vois c'est ce genre de
choses pourrait faire tourner le match
quand même encore en cas de 3-0
calcul rénale tu es pas bien non non
mais bon
globalement ça c'est improbable quoi
il réfléchit en tout cas on nous propose
4 quand même j'ai pas trop l'idée alors
il rentre dans le foot couleur opposé
donc tu parlais mais qu'on n'a pas vu je
vais remontré les coups faut prendre F5
et prends F5 puis on prend puis on prend
puis on prend puis on prend faut prends
on reprend tu auras des 1 ouais bon du
coup soyez que on va gagner soit il y
aura nul mais déjà il y a aucun danger
dans le sens inverse et tu es un peu
mieux parce que
tu as une tour qui va rentrer alors ça
peut être un peu étonnant de vous dire
ça il y a les pions sur case noire et
vous pouvez vous dire oui il y a le
fossile fou sur 15 ans mais le truc
c'est qu'on peut pas attaquer la base et
le problème c'est que sur le seul moyen
de limiter les tours
mais tu échange et ta faute
donc là doivent échanger normalement
c'est en faveur des noirs de jouer pour
la nul en faisant ça mais on va se
perdre un pion alors après peut-être on
peut tenir la nulle dans cette finale
mais bon il faudra galérer quoi
c'est peut-être même la meilleure option
d'ailleurs de rentrer dans cette finale
et de ce des carcasses mais bon bah en
fait en général quand il y a toujours
fou sur clairement les chances de gains
que quand il y a que des fous donc par
principe tu as envie de faire mais ouais
bon tu as le permis
de la diagonale moi je reviens en E4 et
[ __ ] enfin
moi je penserai qu'elle est perdante
personnellement
qui sera passé peut-être tu dois vite
faire le 4 3 bon je sais pas trop si
c'est si gênant toute façon il se fait
arrêter facile aussi
enfin je sais pas disons que je
pencherai plus pour perdre mais après
c'est quoi la règle de la Diego bah que
le fou en fait il arrête les pions sur
la même diagonale tu dois tenir et s'il
écartelé bah tu vas en pousser un pour
le faire bouger et que l'autre il parte
c'est par exemple s'il devait s'il doit
défendre contre à 5 et C3 bah il va
rester là et il va enfin il savait pas B
en fait il va bloquer le le fou il va se
planter sur une diagonale il va bloquer
les deux mais là le problème c'est que
si tu as le pion à passer le pion g en
fait le fou pour bloquer les deux il va
devoir se mettre sur une diagonale et
quand il aura chopé un l'autre avancera
quoi
et c'est plus difficile de faire des
défenses combinées roi fou aussi dans
ces cas-là
donc voilà après parce que le roi il
peut plus facilement venir aider le fou
et bloquer le 3 si des fois que sur une
diagonale
j'avais fait une master light là dessus
que vous pouvez retrouver sur Youtube ou
c'est hyper bien expliqué
c'est très bien très bien expliqué il
reste déjà plus que 5 minutes à Douda
c'est sur la chaîne principale sur la
chaîne principale
déjà de zéro que tu as cette position au
blanc et qui a que huit parties bon tu
sifflotes tu peux danser tranquille
c'est vraiment très facile pour IKO ce
match
trop pas mis en danger par le
vice-champion du monde de Blitz
pas du tout
non là c'est
pas que c'est facile c'est qu'il a même
pas même pas sourcier quoi que dans la
partie précédente si la paire mais bon
il domine bien souvent
tu dis bon ok même si on perdue une fois
de 100 ans il a trop de marge
tu imagines 3-0 il va peut-être
peut-être que au bout de 5 parties notre
est fini quoi demain on est 18h on est
tranquille ok donc il rentre dans la
fameuse finale donc il va retourner fou
c'est vite
et il va prendre à 6
et donc le plan des blancs c'est de
c'est monter le roi E4 et donc avec les
noms a priori oui c'est bien de vivre
tous ces spions
que si le pion reste là et que tu mets
le rang E4 que tu transfères après le
fou et tu décides de quel fin tu pars du
côté que tu peux après ça va être
catastrophique
il va passer sous le baby-foot Douda 3-0
c'est quand même assez humiliant
nombreux joueurs aurait du mal mais bon
mais ça fait jamais plaisir évidemment
donc tu dois avoir ton setup en tête et
il tient il tient pas j'en sais rien
mais réfléchir à de replomber maintenant
de toute façon normalement c'est Baba et
e43 ça ça me paraît les coûts quand même
je sais pas ça change d'abord mais a
priori c'est la même chose
c'est un peu con tant que maintenant
à part principalement
[Musique]
gagnant tu mettras le fond E4 tu
partiras d'un côté avec le roi il sera
protégé tu gagneras peut-être qu'il
espère te laisser avec Cash et donner le
fou contre a quoi
mais bon ça a l'air d'être complètement
à cas de figure improbable quoi ouais
bon ok du coup tu fais P ah et BC il
veut
5 si tu veux vraiment pas ce truc
soit je me demande même si tu fais ton
roi des trois je suis pas contre c'est
BCB à Bab un cours 4 on va dire qu'il
fait fout des quatre et tu pousses un
peu là-bas un peu des deux côtés je sais
pas ouais mais il doit vouloir te les te
forcer à partir avec le roi vers B
etc chier à te faire un chantage il se
fait Roy F4 et du coup pour éviter
peut-être je fais abb-5
et tu mets le rang 4 et
il pourra jamais faire C4 il va pousser
le pion avec le fou en C4 toi
bon
je peux pas dire que j'aime pas assez
simple après
j'aurais l'impression que j'ai une
tellement facilement avec les Blancs
c'est bizarre
je vois très bien le plan se mettre en
place mais après ces trucs de foot
couleur opposé des fois tu as
l'impression que tu vas gagner
et en fait pas du tout
non mais c'est une bonne
j'aurais du mal à comprendre ce que ça
change vraiment d'avoir le pion B plutôt
que le pion a par principe je préfère le
pion a mais bon
non mais c'est juste pour éviter l'autre
truc en fait
non mais du coup je l'éviterai je me
prendrais pas la tête à pas l'éviter
de toute façon il va calculer hein
cette position et
après il fait un peu d'acting aussi car
où on le connaît le marlou
on connaît les marlots
et Wesley qui a déjà fait nul contre
André King
pas trop gérer non plus
belle affiche en tout cas entre les deux
hommes
en réflexion on va voir moi je suis
intéressé de voir comment il va tenter
de la gagner je trouve la finale est
intéressante
ouais tout à fait
et leur dit propose de faire fouter 7 et
sur CB il fait quoi il fait à 6
leur dit il y a une comme ça
du coup tu veux échanger les pions il te
fait
assises et en fait il te bloque il va te
ramener le rang enfin genre
en fait il va t'en faire enfin tu seras
obligé de faire baisser 5 et du coup il
obtient ce qu'il veut obtenir quoi de
toute façon tu as même ton roi là-bas
il a tenté de faire la même chose il a
compris il a fait fou B5
Abassi il a compris et G4 c'est terminé
et en fait quand tu ramènes le roi
le truc qui est sale c'est que tu en
fermes le fou donc il pourra pas
sacrifier très bien joué
ça aurait peut-être un changer mais tu
sens que il est bien bien pourri donc
voilà ce qui s'envole jolie
ça c'est joli c'est bien fait
il a compris un truc important
de bloquer le fou ouais bon ça fait 3-0
Fab
oh il danse ça y est
le match est plié abandon
Sada de chez défonce Sada
ouais bah match match des eaux pour
entre guillemets cette grosse affiche
qui
ouais qui accouche d'une souris
j'en ai marre je préfère pas passer sous
le Baby quoi
qu'est-ce que tu veux aller voir Sarine
ouais
très bien
je vais récupérer les cames du coup je
vais les changer
je pense pas qu'on revienne sur sur ce
match enfin lequel
mais oui voilà il y a plus intérêt dans
le match en fait on va dire
les dés sont jetés
on a déjà les résultats match un peu
décevant mais bon
ok non
car forme ouais ouais
il est toujours en forme en fait
bravo bravo à lui bravo et Caro
qui mérite amplement
on va récupérer ses vieux enseignant qui
avait
éliminé Maxime
alors
franchement il avait bien joué
Maxime qui avait peut-être pas assez
pris le match au sérieux
comme ça et puis bon il se passe ce qui
se passe
je suis en train de faire n'importe quoi
une nouvelle fois avec les cames
mais je vais avoir la cam de séviant et
on va voir quand elle va partir
ouais les cames
la cam de 5 qui part pas pour le voir
celle de séviants et on va on va laisser
c'est peut-être un bug qui va
qui va se régler tout seul donc séviant
avec les Blancs
et la position semble assez égale Fab
ouais ouais
qui mène et puis qui est jamais en
difficulté donc c'est bien
donc ouais
[Musique]
qui peut l'arrêter
on verra enfin peut se faire arrêter à
tout moment mais ouais mais il manque
quand même des gros noms pour
remarque qui peut l'arrêter dans ce
format je sais pas peut-être personne
mais tu vois il manque un allié resa il
manque il manque des joueurs un peu de
se calibre là pour essayer d'avoir un
frisson
donc oui c'est dur
mais je pense pas non plus il a même pas
tenté de se qualifier en fait à Lisa
il y a même pas essayé il y a raison
ouais
je te rassure
ah bah oui tu vas tu vas le voir quand
ça va jouer sur echiki réel pour les
candidats là tu le verras
encore qu'il a recommencé à jouer un peu
les titles mais je pense que c'est parce
qu'il veut un peu de pratique un peu
comme Baki en fait peu de clics comme ça
et deux trois trucs
juste pour pour s'entretenir mais il
fait pas les tournois entre guillemets
internet d'ailleurs il a pas joué le
championne store non plus chez Magnus il
a tout refusé
internet tu as pas mal de joueurs comme
ça quand même qui ont complètement
laissé tomber j'ai plus recettes
ouais qui n'arrive pas à avoir de
résultats en fait sur Internet et donc
qui préfère juste délaisser le ses
compétitions
on verra les raisins bien évidemment
décembre championnat du monde de [ __ ]
c'est rapide c'est à dire peut-être pour
ça un qui commence gentiment à reprendre
les titles etc
ça démarre quand les candidats alors je
pense que c'est en mars 2024 Fab ça
devrait être
je sais pas
mais la phase de qualification c'est pas
annoncé enfin le
25 après parce que je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
2023 donc l'année prochaine c'est les la
phase de qualification candidat les
candidats c'est 2024 normalement
je suis pas en avril
en avril 2025 donc
peut-être les candidats ils seront plus
tard enfin tu vois ils ont ils ont
décalé d'une année parce que le match
devait être en novembre puis après il
devait être en mars avril puis
maintenant il va peut-être être en juin
c'est vrai qu'on a peut-être perdu un an
là
donc j'en sais rien en fait ils ont
sauvé le cycle mais bon ah ouais non
c'est vrai tu as raison je m'étais pas
fait la réflexion mais c'est vrai qu'à
force de décaler deux trois quatre cinq
six mois on a peut-être perdu une un
match de championnat du monde en fait au
bout d'un moment tu perds des années
2004 le prochain titre de champion du
monde mais avant tu vas pas rester
champion du monde 6 mois quoi
ouais mais c'était 107 en 2022 oui mais
bon
ce match de base il était annonçant en
novembre 2022 ouais ce match précisément
donc il est passé de novembre 2022 à
mars 2023 et là il est en train de
passer en juin donc en fait ils ont huit
ou neuf mois de retard franchement c'est
comme c'est la coupe du monde de foot
tout d'un coup bon là il se trouve que
moi elle tombe en décembre mais c'est
couchez pas les Jeux Olympiques tu dis
Paris et puis finalement c'est Paris
et tout d'un coup tu dis oui bon en fait
il sera pas juillet 2024 ce sera en mars
2025 bon
enfin pas grand chose mais ça change un
peu le suivant oui puis bon le suivant
tu redis tu redécales de Vima c'est bon
au bout d'un moment tu fais sauter un
tu fais ce temps
il se calme pourquoi 2024 pour que ça
doit être 2022 alors qu'on a joué l'an
dernier c'était en décembre l'année le
match normalement ça devrait être tous
les ans un truc comme ça c'est tous les
ans tout le temps soit en fait c'est
tous les deux ans c'est ce qui prévoit
et tu le fais dans 2 ans c'était en
décembre dans un an quoi puis voilà en
fait c'est pas grave mais tu peux juste
faire des champion du monde tout le
temps et de faire un calendrier que tu
es jamais à jour tu sais pas tu
l'organisme ton pls aussi ça part du
fait que les candidats ils ont ils ont
pris enfin ils ont fait n'importe quoi
oui mais
[Musique]
après après je dois dire que sia un
championnat du monde de Blitz et rapide
dans un mois et demi et que tu sais même
pas où c'est encore c'est pas super
étonnant qu'il prenne du retard non mais
ça te montre l'étendue de des génies
qu'on met en place mais
c'est pas giga surprenant qui est des
problèmes quoi quand les championnats du
monde
parce qu'il y en a tout le temps en fait
et il y a jamais un truc qui se passe
normalement on peut se dire bon bah là
pour une fois il y a rien à dire quoi
enfin ça va place ça va jamais quoi
je veux dire même la face de de calife
des prochains candidats donc il doit
commencer en juin en début d'année c'est
même pas vraiment annoncé enfin en fait
on sait même pas en fait comment ça
marche il y a même pas les règles en
fait le règlement n'est même pas là
encore
de règlement encore non mais c'est vrai
quand il pense c'est comme si là la
Ligue des Champions tu avais pas la
règlement pour l'année prochaine quoi on
sait pas comment tu te qualifies qui
pourquoi peut-être 8e de championnat ça
va
dans un match peut-être match contre
double non c'est vrai tu as raison tu as
raison le souligner c'est à dire qu'on
ne sait pas quoi
c'est surprise chaque fois
alors que c'est ton truc principal enfin
c'est pas le petit tournoi du quoi on
s'en fout en fait
tout le monde joue pour ça quoi enfin
c'est le seul truc qui compte
[Musique]
c'est complexe femme
pas surtout qu'ils ont pas eu
je veux dire autant quand il y avait le
covid à l'époque tu peux comprendre
cette même coup dans le calendrier et
voilà mais là bon c'est fini et là tu
peux repartir sur des basses saines et
prévoir pour la suite tu as pas quand il
y a des éléments imprévus et des
éléments imprévus et tu fais avec mais
bon
complexe
championnat du monde ça devait être en
mars avril
ouais bah ils vont ils vont plus ou
moins y arriver à quelques mois d'écart
peut-être
et ça va répéter
tu peux pas tenter de gagner avec les
Blancs ici même si Dame cavalier est
plus fort ouais
les pièces et
bon il tente ça
on sait pas trop ce qui te rentre
et c'est bien ça peut lui faire un beau
chèque quand même je sais plus combien
c'est demi-finale lui a peut-être 35 ans
60000 balles pour quelqu'un qui devait
pas être là
ouais bah écoute si
[Musique]
comme le Danemark et 92
peut-être il va aller au bout
en plus il est dans la bonne partie de
tableau et du coup rajabov alors je vais
peut-être pas changer les noms parce que
j'imagine que la partie est quasiment
terminée
c'est Guiri au blanc je vais pas changer
le j'aurais pas le temps de changer les
cames ça joue là parce que il avion de
plus quoi en fait guérir donc il va pas
faire nul comme ça quoi enfin tu vas
faire nul ça en arrive à gagner mais il
va pas juste répéter sans rien faire
ouais ouais mais il peut mettre il va
pouvoir mettre le point
peut-être contre Raja bof
je suis quand même impressionné par NACA
je me répète mais quelle performance
nettement honnêtement supérieur à son
adversaire
mais bon du coup probablement tout le
monde quoi
je pense aussi j'ai du mal à le voir
trébuchet
surtout sur huit parties en fait ça
serait sur une tu sais jamais
sur deux
mais 8 ça te laisse la marge même si tu
fais le con sur une bon ça va
bon on va quand même parti si ils ont 50
secondes chacun donc ça peut être animé
les blancs sont mieux mais
à trois et un bel avantage blanc avec ce
pion qui est propre mais c'est pas
toujours facile d'avancer dans ces
positions bizarrement non non il va
falloir je pense petit à petit simplifié
en fait non mais c'est pas simple non
non non
[Musique]
c'est pas fait mais avantage aux joueurs
batave
c'est jamais fait ces trucs là avec les
dents en plus tu peux cliquer beaucoup
de cours rapide ou tu fais rien
parce que c'est au blanc de prendre leur
responsabilité tactique entre guillemets
à un moment donné
je lui demande si le roi il serait pas
bien en F1 bizarrement
moi ça réfléchit beaucoup je suis rentré
es 7 il se barre il revient voilà raison
c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est à dire
essayer de ne rien faire
si c'est nul c'est exceptionnel
de tenter un tour 5 G5 H4 il revient
c'est plus facile à jouer avec les Noirs
ce truc là
ce qui est assez incroyable
me dites pas qui va la gagner
dommage 2 peut-être pour éviter les
surprises en H3
mais regarde c'est guéri qui va se
retrouver en sueur
quand même
ça ressemble à Beyblade sans fait il a
oublié de me dire
ça ressemble à mes parties plus qu'autre
chose parce que j'ai 5 là non
peut-être qu'il va arriver
voilà c'est pièces net en plus qu'il
avait un pion de plus de base
non non
il a voulu
dans un match aussi serré que celui-là
avec beaucoup de match nul une défaite
fait mal exactement
mais bon sa tête décanter la suite de ce
match et forcer à prendre un peu plus de
risques peut-être même si c'est encore
long les gens se retrouvent demain
il suffit d'en gagner une pour égaliser
mais ça fait un petit avantage pris par
par Aniche jardin match une victoire est
moins tu sens là que ça va être
cadenassé quoi
c'est un peu comme le séviant Sarine
j'ai quoi trop il a réussi à
créer des pseudos menaces mais mon tour
des quatre ça ferme
ah ça va il a bien géré
[Musique]
qui prend une option et il y a plus
d'égalité dans ces matchs non c'est tous
les joueurs ont pris des des options
alors Naka qui s'est complètement volé
Wesley qui mène un zéro enfin zéro ouais
qui a une victoire à zéro guérit une
victoire à zéro aussi et c'est bien une
victoire à zéro
ok bon après bah du coup on peut suivre
le match que tu veux pour la quatrième
partie
qu'est-ce que vous voulez suivre ben on
va demander au public
comme ça de loin voir le score sera
large mais déjà à deux et demi en 2020
j'allais demander ce que tu penses qu'on
fait quand même la quatrième et moi
j'aurais pensé oui mais la 3-0 c'est
trop
sauf en vrai ok on peut regarder ça
c'est celui qu'on a pas du tout regardé
donc on pourra on n'a pas le guerrier
aussi bah sinon on fait un vote
on peut faire un vote et voilà
comme ça c'est fait
je mettrai que le nom d'un joueur je
vais mettre celui qui en haut donc c'est
ça
[Musique]
dommage pour Maxime ça te fait éliminer
par séance parce qu'en fait même s'il
est allé jusqu'à les vols
éliminé il aurait pu y être Maxime et en
plus il aurait eu un premier tour contre
Sarine qui était plus que prenable
exactement
[Musique]
les trois Américains qui pourraient se
qualifier effectivement
il manque quand même en Slimane dans
cette compétition Fab
non pour faire parler pour faire les
choux gras des médias
[Musique]
il y aura pas de procès il y a pas de
problème
dommage on aurait pu en parler quoi il y
aura pas de procès
c'est sûr en fait
quelle marche
[Musique]
si réussi à avoir un arrangement
c'est sûr qu'il va tenter l'arrangement
c'est ce que je voulais dire mais
d'autres vont accepter de s'arranger on
va lui dire bon on va te défoncer ou pas
c'est beau qui est genre 10000 balles
quoi prendre 10000 dollars dans ta
gueule non mais je sais pas qui pourra
les prendre mais c'est sûr que tu as
souvent comme par exemple je les vois
pas enfin bon on sait pas mais pas
comment ça va se passer mais quelque
part tu t'avoues tu as vu ta faute entre
guillemets si tu bon bah c'est ça j'ai
surpris que enfin que neiman veut bien
qu'un arrangement ça je peux comprendre
mais que les autres s'arrangent
surtout si tu es sûr de ton fait
genre je veux dire cheesecom bon ils
t'ont sorti un argumentaire de 72 pages
ouais avec des stats des machins je sais
pas je vois pas trop ce qui viennent
avec un truc un peu béton quoi
bon c'est une petite pause là il est où
ça finit plus tard 10 minutes de pause
et on revient pour pour la dernière
partie du jeu
allez à toute suite
[Musique]
alors les amis on est de retour
en espérant qu'on est les bonnes cames
guérir à jabov
Fab on va essayer de suivre cette partie
voilà
je me perds avec
je me perds avec les noms parce qu'en
fait ouais pour que ça marche bien je
dois changer les noms moi à chaque fois
donc c'est pas un problème mais
en fait je me mélange entre les cames et
les noms et donc ça me fait un
schmilblick dans le cerveau et je me
perds un peu mais oui tu as raison
Sandrine en plus on va pas leur visage
ils sont pas encore revenus ça a
peut-être pris un petit peu de retard
Fab
dommage d'avoir cette horreur là qui qui
était une très très bonne idée et de
quand même réussir à être en retard
malgré les 25 minutes de pause mais moi
je suis à démarre la pendule
non mais c'est un peu dommage en fait
c'est pas grave c'est en soi mais c'est
dauphin dommage de mettre autant de
pause et de quand même réussir à pas
être à l'heure quoi
non mais en soi mais c'est dommage
mais en fait je sais pas finalement
pourquoi pas reprendre direct après
bah là l'idée elle est quand même
louable non mais l'idée louable il faut
réussir c'est ça
un truc pour que ce soit lisible et
qu'on sache vraiment et il réussisse
quand même à être un peu alors ouais
c'est deux trois minutes de retard c'est
pas énorme mais bon
c'est dommage quoi
c'est censé reprendre à 20h ouais alors
ça va pas reprendre à 20h15 attention il
y aura plein de petits retard mais c'est
dommage de ouais
je pense ouais je crois
non c'est sûr mais bon on est parti sont
sont annoncés toutes les heures c'est
dommage
après c'est pas grave
tu dis 20h les gens arrivent à 20h05 et
20h15 ouais non mais enfin c'est tu vois
c'est comme au foot l'habitant c'est 15
minutes enfin c'est pas un moment donné
de manière complètement aléatoire 19
minutes
pas trop comment dire en fait là c'est
bien pensé
ouais à mettre en place en fait sur
place il rentre pas chez eux ça va bien
après ça change pas grand chose mais
c'est dommage
c'est des petits détails
qui ne sont pas graves
non non
on s'en fout c'est pas grave mais c'est
dommage
tu sais pas pourquoi en fait c'est pas
si tu veux trader pour la Ligue des
Champions ça peut jouer quoi
bah disons que des
Grands Prix de Formule 1 quoi c'est 14h
quoi c'est pas 14h04 quoi
ça arrive qui est du retard pour pour
des raisons alors là c'est Douda Naka
qui reprend
alors eux ils ont l'air d'être à l'heure
alors après c'est peut-être son nom mais
c'est la première
bon il y a du retard on sait pas
pourquoi
mais tu vois même là
ah oui ok
ah mais c'est magnifique en fait crieda
[Musique]
par rapport au public mais bon les
joueurs ont quand même pris cette mode
de faire ces trucs là de Shia la gueule
du public de ceux qui les payent
à la rigueur une robe oui mais pourquoi
pas enfin tu peux faire B4 tu peux faire
des trucs un peu originaux mais qui est
juste pas ça quoi
ah ouais ouais c'est pas
ça donne pas une belle image du sport
professionnel
je suis un vieux con et c'est pas grave
mais ça me plaira jamais ça c'est aussi
possible
en fait
donc c'est très possible je suis plus en
phase avec ce qui se passe mais bon je
préfère vivre dans mon trou tranquille
que voir ça quoi
après qu'est-ce que tu veux c'est tant
qu'il y a pas de sanction et que tout le
monde trouve ça normal moi j'ai déjà eu
le débat sur les
E407 de Nakamura contre terrible et les
gens disent que ça amusant et que c'est
drôle ben ouais ok pas tellement enfin
moi j'ai jamais trouvé ça drôle quoi
c'est enfin tant mieux pour eux enfin
après on se retrouve avec des
accusations de n'importe enfin c'est le
résultat en fait de tout ça on est dans
le grand n'importe quoi tu défends plus
tes titres de champion enfin tu fais
n'importe quoi de A à Z et puis c'est
enfin c'est marrant
mais
on a l'impression que le monde c'est
enfin c'est pas truut c'est pas Twitter
quoi c'est pas faire de blagues de fin
je sais pas j'ai pas l'impression que
quand je regarde du tennis ou quoi on se
[ __ ] de ma gueule comme ça mais après
non non ça a des conséquences mais non
dans l'exemplarité que tu donnes aux
plus jeunes ou à la relève au futur
génération en tout cas c'est
c'était pas ça quoi mais je veux dire tu
prends tous les champions du passé ils
ont jamais fait ça quoi non mais je vois
pas
on a perdu des trucs pareils
non mais tu vois ça me fait un peu
penser comme si au tennis à un moment
donné tu avais je sais pas tu avais un
match entre deux mecs Roland Garros ou
je sais pas n'importe quel tournant en
fait on s'en fout et que les mecs pour
rigoler se donner deux trois jours que
des double faute et il se marrer
double faute j'ai fait j'ai fait 10
double faute ils sont à 6 6 si je vous
le tie break et il s'agit avec un peu
mais en fait si tu faisais ça ben
juste tu te serais viré enfin genre les
le public te te cracherait dessus en
fait c'est ça et amende du tournoi et
Machin et puis il y a des conséquences
peut-être tu perds tes sponsors enfin il
se passe des choses en fait mais bon si
aux échecs c'est bien continuons aux
échecs ça fait rire mais bon j'ai envie
de te dire si c'était le problème
principal des échecs ça on serait aussi
très bien parce que c'est
un problème
tout le temps ouais c'est qu'en fait les
institutions sont pas fortes quoi et
laisse tout faire tout et n'importe quoi
ah bah oui mais bon c'est ça ça de
grosse conséquences après mais bon non
mais voilà ça porte son nom c'est une
exhibition donc là ils sont contents ils
sont faire des smatchs ils défendent des
fois ils passent de trait du filet mais
en fait ils en ont rien à [ __ ] de qui
viennent type hyper c'est pas un tournoi
là il se trouve c'est un tournoi il y a
un million de prix en fait enfin
c'est de l'argent en fait
c'est ça va
pas pour tout le monde apparemment non
pas apparemment pas pour tout le monde
pas pour tout le monde après
tu peux comprendre qu'un million soit
pas de l'argent pour tout le monde non
plus enfin tu vois c'est de l'argent
pour moi mais pas forcément pour tout le
monde
mais en cette partie
bah écoute alors là au moins ça joue aux
échecs
bon c'était une Anglaise ouais position
assez solide donc une structure où les
blancs la majorités
[Musique]
je sens qu'il va bouger
et bon c'est assez équilibré
on en discutait aussi sur le live on
disait c'est vrai que
quand des joueurs quand les joueurs
donnent pas l'exemple tu vois même
au niveau de la triche quand les tout
tout meilleur du monde voir même
champion du monde ne donne pas l'exemple
c'est un problème tu peux pas après dire
à des gars qui jouent
en amateur ou qui joue pour le plaisir
c'est grave d'avoir quelqu'un d'autre
qui joue sur ton compte ou genre de
choses ou qui ou qui t'aident et qui
donne des coups quand tu as le champion
du monde de la discipline qui le fait
forcément on peut pas après en vouloir à
des joueurs de de d'un niveau moindre de
de faire pareil c'est toujours c'est
toujours le même problème si si c'est
toléré pour le top top c'est ça doit
d'autant plus être toléré pour pour les
amateurs
mais
mais disons en fait ce qu'il y a de con
c'est que une des valeurs normalement du
sport c'est justement le respect de du
sport en général de l'adversaire
etc et là je vois plus ça je vois pas ça
en fait trop souvent dans trop de
tournant et ça commence à être tout
match quoi c'est même pas un problème
d'échappe ou pas d'échec quoi c'est un
vrai plus global quoi
ouais ouais tu as pas ça manque un
manque de respect comme je disais c'est
pas par rapport à l'adversaire c'est
vraiment par rapport au public et tout
ça tu dois donner le meilleur que toi
après que ton adversaire tu penses
pendant la partie et ça a beaucoup de
sportifs dans tous les sports à chaque
fois que tu en parles il pense pareil tu
penses à être un con que machin qui va
le défoncer ça c'est complètement normal
c'est là pour te donner à fond mais
après pas respecter le politique en
faisant n'importe quoi ça c'est quand
même terrible en fait que tu aies
confiance et que tu as besoin de ça pour
te motiver c'est quelque chose enfin
c'est même pas le problème mais tu te
fous pas de sa gueule en fait en faisant
des trucs comme ça enfin c'est comme si
tout d'un coup tu joues main gauche au
tennis qu'au foot et c'est plus que
mettre des petits ponts en fait ça passe
pas il le tu le fais pas puis si tu le
fais tu vas te prendre un [ __ ] de tac
et ça va pas traîner en fait donc c'est
très vite voilà enfin faire un petit
pont sur une action tu as le droit mais
c'était le geste à tenter c'est que
cetera mais tu vas pas jouer que pour ça
et faire tes petites roulettes et tes
petits machins enfin
tu vas voir ce qui t'arrive quoi
ça va vraiment pas
que le tennis
viens faire ta petite volé on va voir on
va voir peut-être pas te faire un
passing cette fois quoi bien comme il
faut non mais le truc c'est qu'en fait
c'est même pas les joueurs qui prennent
des sanctions enfin là tu parlais de
l'exemple avec Benoît Paire qui est un
exemple connu c'est juste l'ATP en fait
qui te dit ok enfin c'est soit tu
arrêtes tu arrêtes ça tout de suite ou
sinon tu pourras juste plus jouer les
tournants on va te suspendre et puis
c'est fini en fait bah oui c'est en fait
tu vas te faire ban
imagine au tennis pour reprendre
l'exemple mais ça pourrait être
n'importe quel sport tu refuses de
je sais pas moi en quart de finale de
Roland-Garros et tu refuses de jouer ton
quart de finale tu te pointes pas et tu
dis le mec se dope donc je n'irai pas
jouer
oui
tu as planté tout le monde enfin en fait
qu'est-ce qui va
c'est soit tu vas t'excuser soit tu as
plus jouer en fait ouais puis a priori
tu restes de pas jouer pendant un petit
moment même tu t'excuses en fait tu as
peut-être juste prendre moins cher que
ce que tu aurais pris sinon mais bah tu
vas prendre une amende enfin tu vas te
faire défoncer concrètement parce que
c'est un peu c'est l'équivalent de ça
qui s'est passé avec manus et il s'est
absolument rien passé au contraire c'est
vrai tiens on va essayer de non non ça
passerait pas du tout tu peux tu peux
pas faire ça
c'est pas possible
j'ai du mal à imaginer un endroit où ça
passe en fait je sais pas on parle de
foot on parle de tennis mais il y a
plein de sport je connais pas mais non
mais ça passerait nulle part en fait ça
peut pas c'est pas possible en fait tu
peux pas
[Musique]
ça passerait dans aucun donc quasiment
aucun domaine en dehors du sport en fait
c'est juste pas possible
c'est parti bon on a plus ou moins
échangé un petit peu ce profiler
un breaking il a fait grand rock non
mais parce que c'est des trucs hein
cette partie
ça peut ça peut la jauge en tout cas dis
rien pour le moment
non elle dit rien il est parti
équilibrées
en fait donc on peut appeler certains
peuvent plus se permettre de choses
qu'ailleurs alors que il y a pas de
raison enfin c'est ok ça joue très bien
aux échecs bah c'est bien mais c'est
tout en fait ça donne pas plus de droit
moins de droit
ouais non mais qu'est-ce que tu veux
c'est
je suis en train de commenter un tournoi
en fait
mais ouais non mais j'ai écouté ce que
tu disais en parallèle mais oui
parce que tu as l'impression aux échecs
bien joué aux échecs et synonymes
d'intelligence donc si tu es champion du
monde est très intelligent alors que pas
forcément bah tu peux ou pas mais c'est
pas
c'est pas la même famille c'est pas dit
quoi non non
pour être sérieux je pense quand même
que Nadal se pointe pas en quart de
Roland au minimum ça fait des bas ça
serait pas aussi simple ah non mais
c'est il se prend pas en car et il
accuse ouvertement son adversaire de
stopper qui veut plus jouer contre lui
et il apporte aucune preuve c'est pas ça
c'est juste qu'on dirait c'est un c'est
un pauvre con en fait non mais déjà les
mecs
défoncer Nadal si faisait ça enfin je
veux dire quand les mecs sont un peu
blessés ils se font violence pour venir
quand même jouer se battre ouais mais je
veux dire tu vois tellement que ils ont
pas envie que ça se fait pas de pas
venir quoi donc en plus faire tout ça on
en parle même pas quoi
tu regardes Zidane avec le coup de boule
personne n'en veut bah il s'est pris
carton rouge en fait Zidane
il a accusé personne de rien il pète un
plomb dans un match enfin je veux dire
c'est mais c'est très différent
et personne ne félicite
après on peut comprendre ce qui se passe
parce que tu es pas il y a de
l'attention
c'est comme ça quoi
euh ça ça a aucun rapport en fait c'est
pas
enfin tu vois c'est un truc sur le coup
de l'émotion ça dure quelques secondes
c'est pas réfléchi en amont plein il y a
énormément de différence quand même
puis ça en fera pas des lois
pas tu prends ton rouge quoi la petite
suspendu pour quelques matchs après bon
il se trouve la tarte donc tu t'en fous
mais tu l'esthésique etc
puis bon pour le geste tu vas quand même
être suspendu enfin
la plus grosse bourre de sa carrière bah
il a déjà pris d'autres cartons rouges
mais sinon c'est la plus connu c'est en
finale de Coupe du monde et en plus si
la France finissait par gagner le match
au tir au but ça aurait été oublié mais
tu finis par perdre en plus quoi donc
c'est un peu assimilé que il y a eu ça
et que ça fait perdre la France alors
que peut-être rater la même chose
tu n'en sais rien et voilà et puis bon
il ira plus usine à cette Coupe du Monde
bah déjà tu participes même pas mais bon
toujours est-il que oui non c'est deux
trucs différents ça c'est comme on va
dire tu vois c'est comme je suis au
tennis ta raquette
c'est un geste d'humeur d'énervement
t'as pas le faire et puis l'arbitre peut
te mettre un warning peut te faire
siffler tu vois même une amende peu
importe comme Djoko qui avait mis
du match mais ça c'est tu peux avoir un
geste d'humeur et ok bon pas déjà tu
dois pas mais c'est humain on est tous
humains et on peut flotter et puis tu as
autre chose que après ou tu
décides à froid de prendre une posture
etc donc c'est différent
Zinédine en plus qui a pas de bol
puisque c'est la première fois qu'on va
utiliser la barre dans l'histoire du
football ah mais on devait pas en plus
parce que ça existait pas là c'est juste
fou après il doit se prendre
moi j'aurais fait pareil que l'arbitre
un personnage
qui te dit il te le dis mais tu l'as vu
sur l'écran géant donc une fois que tu
l'as vu c'est normal de mettre carton
rouge
tu sais que ça arrive le truc c'est que
si tu avais vu enfin tu avais pas se
fait penalty avec une minute après tu
vois qui est pédalier tu vas pas revenir
dessus
enfin c'était pas tempo ouais bon c'est
normal qui est carton
donc il finit par le voir quand même
ouais mais il l'a vu enfin c'est ce que
je vais faire là c'est qu'en fait il l'a
vu
c'est comme Maradona si tu vois citation
l'écran tu vois qu'il y a main et que tu
as pas encore redonné le coup d'envoi
c'est sûr que tu vas
payer mais bon
après la question c'est ce qui doit
faire
c'est le réalisateur qui le met sur
l'écran entre guillemets qui fait la
différence
en fait
le truc c'est qu'il fallait juste pas de
télé enfin c'est juste ça le truc vu
qu'il y avait pas de Var à l'époque
ouais mais après après le truc c'est que
ils ont jamais le geste est trop visible
en fait sur les petits trucs tu dois
jamais tu regardes tu vois jamais puis
là en fait tu vois le mec qui te met un
coup enfin c'est
qui peut pas y avoir de simulation je
sais pas c'est que tu es sûr à 100% que
ça arrivait c'est sûr enfin ce que je
veux dire c'est que
en fait derrière pour des trucs comme ça
je peux pas être contre la barre parce
que tu répares ok un truc qui est
flagrant
là pour les trucs ou tu es sûr de rien
et tu regardes mille fois il y a eu un
cas de figure hier dans un match
Liverpool - Napoli
qui est refusé un but genre on sait même
pas enfin du front mais en fait là tu es
pas sûr parce que tu sais pas exactement
à quelle fraction de seconde la balle
part ou pas quoi il y a un truc que
j'arrive tu vois j'ai du mal à
comprendre avec ça dans dans le foot
c'est que au rugby ça marche très bien
mais j'ai l'impression qu'au foot si tu
sais jamais en fait non mais quand tu
sais comme là par exemple c'est clair tu
sais des fois tu as des penalties très
clair mais en fait si tu es pas sûr sur
sûr faites arrête de faire chier que ta
barre mais laisse l'intuition de
l'arbitre sur la pelouse et il décide
qu'il avait décidé en live et puis voilà
mais pourquoi ils font pas ça parce que
c'est ce qu'ils font très très bien ça
pareil par logique je suis d'accord
ça me permet ça fait des années que ça
marche comme ça et si ça marche très
bien en fait tu as l'arbitre qui a son
intuition et puis bah ok si l'avare te
monte par très clairement que oui bah il
y avait un méga je veux oui il y avait
faute oui il y avait coup de boule ou
bon ok ben c'est clair voilà l'arbitre a
pas vu il a pas vu mais là
quand c'est si pas clair que ça et que
ça se joue un dixième de seconde au
moment où tu mets play ou pause sur
l'image
ça reste
c'est pas automatisé ça reste un humain
qui appuie sur pause à un moment ou un
autre donc
ils disent c'est pareil ouais mais en
fait je sais pas au rugby c'est pareil
c'est juste si tu as la question et
c'est
faut vraiment être sûr quoi après le
seul cas où ils font vraiment image par
image mais c'est parce que ça enfin
ça s'y prête bien c'est genre savoir
s'il est passage en touche ou pas
ça c'est un truc que tu vas réellement
souvent voir
au rugby les seuls moments ils sont
vraiment genre à être à l'image sur
image pour savoir ou pas genre les
passes en avant bon ils font comme ils
sont en fait c'est quand même le truc
qui prévoit sur le terrain à moins qu'on
soit sûr le seul truc où ils vont
vraiment aller chercher l'image avec par
image c'est pour voir si le joueur est
passé en touche
mais ça c'est logique parce que là tu
peux vraiment arrêter l'image et
t'arrêter au moment où tu vois donc oui
mais pour les trucs genre est-ce que la
passe est en avant ou pas en fait
ah non c'est soit tu vois vraiment
qu'elle est en avant soit tu sais pas et
si tu sais pas c'est le c'est ce qui est
sur le terrain qui prévoit
et c'est ma partie échec
il attaque la tour elle fout des 5 donc
les Noirs ils vont faire tourner vite
ils vont se laisser prendre en dessin
qui reprend du pion ce qui va être cloué
en C3 et faire un échange et chacun aura
un petit problème de structure soit
peut-être il y a des trucs tactiques à
base de de fou B3 qui font partie
c'est ce qu'il a fait et ça prendra vite
ça va prendre des uns et vers des petits
échanges ici ou là et ça va un peu
liquider c'est sûrement un meilleur
choix de saut parce que quitte à tous
ces échanges autant garder le pion en C6
plutôt que ce soit affaibli en dessin
[Musique]
un tout petit peu mieux pour les noirs
avec le cavalier peut-être un peu plus
facile à jouer mais oui ça doit être
complètement égal
d'une maladie en fait ouais
ça va être important
mais bon c'est vrai qu'avec les blancs
tu vas te replacer le foncé deux si tu
peux envoyer les pions ouais ça doit
être égal en soi
ou tu prends tu iras quand même je sais
pas
tu enlèves la case des trois au four
donc il va faire quoi ces deux je pense
mais
voilà bon
tu es obligé de reprendre à 8
[Musique]
de toute façon tu vas être obligé
d'aller chercher
ce serait déjà joué
proposez nul peut-être
faire chasse à proposer nul exactement
mais bon c'est vrai que si sauce sent un
peu mieux et il a pas trop de risques il
a raison mais il est beau ce cheval
après le foie F3 je crois qu'il est bien
placé aussi
trop dur d'allancer de ce qui serait
bien placé on s'est fait une focale et
il aide les pions mais je pense que tu y
arrives pas vraiment et en plus le
cavalier défend B ouais c'est hyper
chiant
de partir enfin je sais pas trop ce
qu'il va faire en fait c'est tout bon on
est en B4 soit dit non
hyper gaffe de pas se faire fixer les
puntos sur cases blanches
si tu te fais fixer sur case blanche tu
vas être complètement foutu avec les
Blancs
une connerie mais genre G4 h6g5 H5 fin
et là au bout d'un moment tu vas être
perdant bon tu vas jamais faire mais
je me demande si je dois pas faire G5
décalé le fou faire F4 et revenir mais
bon tu vas laisser des tours des trois
après moi ça me ferait super chier de
jouer avec les blancs en fait
non non mais c'est pas ça
en plus en donnant nul il a donné une
info quand même
en proposant qui suit
mais ça c'est une règle qu'on te dit
d'ailleurs pour pour tout le monde mais
bon enfin ah bah niveau encore ça peut
passer parfois mais normalement moi on
m'a toujours dit quand tu es un peu
moins bien ne propose pas nul
ce qui arrive regarde il va se prendre
G5 il va se prendre F6
un mur
des cases c'est horrible bien joué ça
ça c'est horrible à jouer
la décision est chiante entre prendre ou
pas prendre mais surprise et tout
racheter un perso c'est ça mais du coup
tu dois être là-bas mais tu peux plus te
revenir contester la colonne D ou quoi
j'essaierai de m'activer mais bon
ouais tu sens que c'est pas
a priori je prendrai aussi mais bon
ce serait une autre mais tu vois moi
c'est pour ça que j'aurais pas fait
fouger de direct j'aurais fait G5 en
premier
juste avant on disait comment ça te
faire fixer sur casse blanche
et par curiosité
[Musique]
on va retourner sur
et juste par curiosité
il est tranquille et c'était quoi
l'autre c'est Raja bof pardon
[Musique]
sinon sur chasse les leçons vous les
trouvez comment bah c'est moi qui les ai
faites en français donc plutôt bien
frérot
maintenant
parce que il est plus attaché à ses 5 ou
des fonds
intermédiaire parce que ça a touché la
tourelle et il avait un rebondir
très franchement il a peut-être raté
qu'il y avait prime de là
mais normalement tu as pas envie
pas du tout envie en fait
bah quand tu veux
que ça sera plutôt que l'autre aura bien
défendu
je peux pas aller donner une si facile
dans une telle position
après il menace rien avec les Blancs
enfin c'est un truc quand il va rentrer
après je pense qu'il va faire tout rage
5 te forcer F6 puis tourrage 7
d'ailleurs oui sur ton chemin
F6 et surtout h63g7 peut-être et toi
tu cours
du coup moi j'aurais peut-être tenté par
un tour des 7
pour préparer un peu
d'après roi F6 c'est peut-être pas con
aussi après c'est vrai que de rien faire
c'est pas bête dans le sens où si tu
fais tour quelque part il y ait des
trois sont là menaces
mais pourquoi pas enfin c'était un peu
dans le mode je fais rien mais
c'est peut-être pas un bon rien quoi
un pion sur blanc c'est bizarre Mazo
serait très énervé d'un tel coup c'est
pas rien
bah l'autre avec un fou de casse noir et
tu avais la structure idéale avec le
cavalier C5 qui protège B7 qui protège
et ton pion sur noir en fait tu étais
solide
mais là tu perds un peu ta solidité en
quelque sorte non
il fait des choses
en fait juste tu as envie de jouer à 5
là
en vrai
là il sait pas trop il patine il patine
en fait il a envie de rien faire et
d'attendre la faute le problème c'est
qu'il arrive pas
rien faire c'est bien joué mais en fait
fallait le fin c'est le coup qu'il
fallait faire juste avant
et tu tournicotes un peu quoi tu vas
peut-être vérifier
si tu peux
c'est plutôt une bonne option en général
de bouger les pièces juste dans ses
positions là j'ose pas mais il a essayé
de me battre hier comme ça
il m'a bougé les pièces ouais il m'a
bougé 50 coups bon bah j'ai rien fait
non plus
j'avais fini par réussir à faire nul
mais j'ai battu un mec avec de la même
manière enfin j'ai battu quelqu'un de la
même manière de partir avant finalement
les mecs défendent pas mal ils font pas
forcément les cons
[Musique]
pas forcément faire quelque chose mais
le truc c'est que tu peux rien faire
pendant très longtemps tu peux le faire
pour toi tu peux rien faire pendant 10
20 30 40 coups et tu es là et tu attends
quoi
[Musique]
et en fait nul c'est pas un mauvais
résultat pour so donc c'est un genre de
chantage au con
geler juste une partie comme ça on open
bon autant on a rien à [ __ ] je pense
on va cavalier F2 et tu dis ça doit être
gagnant mais là c'est donc enfin oui
il te reste que deux parties au noir
tu as pas l'air trop souffrir
tu souffres pas dans le match pourquoi
tu vas t'embêter
ouais c'est un chantage au con ouais
mais c'est chiant en fait
ouais moi je suis avec Je t'emmerde j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] je ne te prends pas le
pion
surtout si prends le pion avec moins
d'une minute ça concept mal joué ça soit
faut le prendre vite parce que tu as vu
soit tant pis je suis plus con que toi
je te le prends pas
ok mais parce qu'il a bien calculé
tourner c'est pas facile c'est bien
désolé il veut peut-être tout rare
et du coup roi B2 tours ici mais tu es
content tu économises un tempo
ils sont forts quand même
je sais pas quelque part
mais bon avec peu de temps pour me faire
gaffe avec le cavalier passe le faire
après tu as des cases quand même tâches
pas tu vas bouffer à trois
pour le moment il est pseudo-défendu par
des tours à deux quand même
tomber 5 mais je veux dire faut faire
gaffe que la fin que la tour se retrouve
pas bloquée du coup le cavalier enfin tu
m'as compris quoi
pour une minute d'avance pour ce
oui parce que il a la position en plus
donc
du coup pour aller bouffer E3
est-ce que j'ai pas une autre option en
fait
je pense qu'il va bouffer non
je pense aussi
à cause de ça
c'est bien ou si enfin tu sais pas si tu
gagnes un temps ou pas
de toute façon j'imagine alors tu qui
viennent de se doute c'est un c'est une
position
et tu gardes le pion C3 en vue non mais
c'est probablement plus fort mais juste
moi je suis assez pleutre et j'ai envie
d'aller au 5 pour faire qui est le 4 il
me paraît de là j'en ai marre là je veux
plus voir ce qu'il y a c'est ce qu'il a
fait aussi mais c'est repartir merci
d'eux il veut qu'il y a
ça dépend des variantes en fait
ok cavalier
pour quelque part tu auras 5 peut-être
là sinon à 5 je pense tu es gagnant
c'est fou quand même comment ce coup ça
c'est pas ça se sentait que tu vas le
payer un jour en fait
peut-être tu as de la chance tu le
paieras pas trop mais ça te complique la
vie
je pense qu'il doit tenter roi B4 ou
apprend à 4 de toute façon
il fait roi des cadres
y ça là
et puis bah voilà c'est tout bah oui
parce qu'au pire le roi il passe par là
tu fais C5 B5 tu as l'impression que tu
fais un mur mais cinq enfin c'est fini
et tu as le décalage par là-bas et s'il
y a en B6 tu feras B4 AB3 et c'est
terminé
merci au revoir bah ce sera Sona caméra
elle a deux points d'avance c'est
c'est la même partie de tableau ouais
ouais ok
ça c'est sûr et du coup il faut voir le
bas du tableau maintenant Fab euh
Raja Bob bon ça c'est complètement
ok on peut rester dessus c'est pas le
temps de changer les noms c'est Raja
BAFA avec les Blancs
contre
il est en dessous bah il est moins bien
dans pas toutes les parties mais quoi si
en fait parce que la première quand il y
a eu la nul c'était
mieux pour guérir
du coup chaque fois qu'on vient c'est
soit mieux d'après la chose ça c'est
plus bon ok ça va faire nul pour le coup
c'est sûr mais
il est carrément dominé
voilà le truc marrant c'est que
finalement il fait de la finale qui
semble un peu chiante il ça risque de
devoir faire un filet d'horreur avec les
Noirs
contre des
dragons ça va être nul facile
[Musique]
une pièce de plus
tu es bloqué après à quel point c'est
facile à gagner ou pas je sais pas mais
pareil c'est viande qui domine bien le
match
largement de la tête et des épaules
la Cigale en fait c'est Vian il tue le
match aussi
plus deux c'est trop c'est pas mal hein
ça peut faire de finir tôt demain quoi
ça va ça va aller au bout de la nuit
parce ce qui est sûr c'est que nacaduda
il y aura pas 8 parties ça je te
l'annonce
je vois pas perdre avec les Blancs enfin
je vois pas perdre du tout mais avec les
Blancs encore moins et puis bah c'est
fini déjà
complètement
terrible
non mais Sarine à chaque fois mal au
temps
j'avais pas fait gaffe mais c'est
bizarre parce qu'il domine les tournois
internet habituellement
un peu différente cadence différente
mais c'est étonnant parce que tous ces
tournants là tu vois même là pour même
pour se qualifier quoi
il s'est encore qualifié et il domine et
Machin et
il est vraiment magnifique
dam dames et à 3 non
je sais pas prise 17 est-ce que il veut
torber 8 sinon
poursuit on s'en fout
pas facile à voir ça non mais c'est ce
que je veux questionner en fait je me
dis c'est ça
que je comprends que ça va pour les
Noirs mais du coup ça te fait quelques
temps bibi tout quoi mais peut-être ton
autre vente elle est pas bête avec le A3
je sais pas
en fait c'est pour faire à 3 à 2 et kb3
et essayer de juste passer le pion en
fait
tu vas devoir rentrer là-dedans ok bon
c'est très bien ouais mais ça c'est pas
si facile enfin c'est pas si facile non
mais bon
il a pas vu juste
c'est trop je pense pour remonter
ouais bah OK
c'est trop facile c'est un truc comme ça
mais ça va aller c'est beaucoup trop
facile
pas si simple à gagner bizarrement bah
en fait c'était pas qui est précises je
crois que tu avais tout d'un coup c'est
pas tout à fait pareil
sacrifié et que tes deux cavaliers
c'est beau Gilou qui a battu
tylerais bien et puis encore plus dur
quoi bah c'est top top mondial surtout
qu'il est très très motivé
plusieurs
son dernier tournoi Gilou
ça fait plaisir
[Musique]
il va tout donner quoi donc bon si je
suis motivé au bout de lui-même mais là
je pensais que peut-être c'était déjà
trop et en fait
triste c'est la ça nous ça nous rajeunit
pas quoi de voir tous ces jeunes tous
ces joueurs que nous on a
admiré qu'on a vu le jeune et tout
prendre leur exemple
ça va peut-être faire nul finalement bah
ouais parce qu'il va pleuvoir
et le roi qui s'échappe
qui est de justesse mais
chat qui perd des casques donc
voilà après il y a quand même beaucoup
de fourchettes possibles et il peut pas
s'en prendre enfin en fait un cavalier
peut pas mettre une fourchette un autre
cavalier c'est important
mais après
il va faire tout rage 4 non je pense
bien placé
facilement en plus malheureusement pour
lui ah il menace m'attendre quand même
après
tu comprends rien
ça laissera un peu de suspense dans ce
match quand même Fab
là c'est un peu comme Raja
ils sont en souffrance mais il
s'accroche
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent pas tout
perdre attention quand même ce qu'il a
le roi sur la bande dès le début
même si c'est complètement nul c'est sûr
[Musique]
bon après
je sais plus il y a qu'un truc de con
pour essayer de gagner mais c'est là tu
vas pas pouvoir le mettre en place en
fait la tour elle est trop bien placée
c'est trop dur en fait même trouver une
idée
en fait faudrait que tu puisses faire
brasser 3 sans me prendre des chèques
quoi peut-être pour avoir une chance
une fois la tour
et là en fait tu menaces rien quoi
c'est terrible d'autant rien menacer
un peu
[Musique]
mais bon ça s'est connu pour faire nul
sans problème
[Musique]
déjà appris cette finale mais j'ai
toujours fait nul même en blitz sans
problème je l'ai jamais ouais
mais au début donc ça a donné un petit
espoir parce que normalement tu galères
tellement juste à le mettre sur la bande
bah là il arrive plus à le remettre mais
en fait même ça ça fait rien
même le remettre sur la bande ouais ça
fait rien après même si tu perds ta tour
ça reste nul
il va réussir à le remettre sur la bande
là quand même
alors il tente un décalage pour mettre
le cahier en dessin
ok
pas de la journée
qui sont déjà quasi pliés c'est Nakamura
Douda et Wesley Quinn avec
respectivement 4 points et deux points
d'avance et de matchs qui sont encore
chauds avec un seul point d'avance c'est
Annie qui mène 2 et demi contre teamora
Jaba fait ça me séviant qui mène 2 et
demi un et demi contre Niall Sarine ben
merci à tous
d'avoir suivi Fab moi je vais aller
faire des
blitzer amuse-toi bien je vais manger
et peut-être regarder un peu de Ligue
des Champions on va voir c'est quoi ce
soir tu vas regarder le PSG toi non non
non je sais pas trop ce que je vais
regarder mais vu qu'il y a peut-être
1000 ans qui Milan Salzburg ça joue pas
la calife ça peut être intéressant
qui vient de s'allumer on l'attendait
merci à toi mon frère à demain Ciao